de vendredi prochain à 22h sur Public
[Musique]
Sénat bonjour à tous ravi de vous
retrouver sur public Sat en direct de la
salle des conférences du Palais du
Luxembourg au Sénat pour un dimanche
très spécial un dimanche consacré aux
élections sénatoriales aujourd'hui près
de 80000 grands électeurs sont appelés
aux urnes pour renouveler la moitié du
Sénat avec plusieurs enjeux la majorité
de droite et du centre va-t-elle être
conforté par ce scrutin le parti
Renaissance le parti d'Emmanuel Macron
va-t-il enfin réussir à s'imposer à la
haute assemblée et puis on verra si le
rassemblement national fait son retour
au sein du Palais du Luxembourg alors ce
midi nous sommes ensemble pendant 2 he
pour décrypter les enjeux de ces
élections sénatoriales grâce à toutes
nos équipes qui sont mobilisé nos
journalistes sont situés dans quatre
points chauds de ce scrutin avec
notamment Samia Deir qui est dans le
Nord en direct de lî bonjour
Samia bonjour Alex alors est-ce que ce
est-ce que ce scrutin des sénatoriales
se passe bien dans le
Nord oui il y a déjà beaucoup de monde
avec près de 6000 grands électeurs
appelés à voter ici à la préf du Nord à
lî merci beaucoup Samia et on reviendra
vous voir dans cette émission pour
décrypter les enjeux de ces sénatoriales
dans le département du Nord nous irons
également en Mosel avec Mathias Arz en
direct de mes dans les hautes scènes
nous serons avec audreet vetaz en direct
de nanter et puis on s'intéressera à la
bataille parisienne des sénatoriales
avec Steve Jourdain en direct de l'Hôtel
de Ville de Paris nous sommes également
avec notre journaliste parlementaire
Quentin Calmet qui va vous détailler ce
midi les premiers résultats qui tombent
pour ces élections sénatoriales
notamment au premier tour dans certains
départements et puis Quentin bonjour
Alexandre Quentin en raison et bien du
décalage horaire en Nouvelle-Calédonie
nous avons un premier résultat définitif
effectivement en Nouvelle-Calédonie les
deux tours sont déjà terminés cette
collectivité d'outrem qui élisait deux
sénateurs et c'est une information
importante la secrétaire d'État à la
citoyenneté soutenue par Renaissance est
batue dans cette collectivité les deux
sénateurs élus sont George naturel qui a
été élu dès le premier tour c'est un élu
divers droite un maire loyaliste et
effectivement on a un deuxème sénateur
élu mais cette fois-ci au second tour et
c'est un fait marquant car Robert xoui
est élu et c'est un élu indépendantiste
c'est la première fois qu'un sénateur
indépendantiste va faire son entrée à la
Chambre haute du parlement Alexandre
alors Quentin pour commencer cette
émission on va voir comment sont
organisé à ces élections sénatoriales et
contrairement à l'Assemblée nationale ce
n'est pas la totalité du Sénat qui est
renouvelé dans ces élections exactement
on va renouveler uniquement la moitié
des sièges sur les 348 sièges de la
Chambre haute il y en a 170 qui sont
renouvelés aujourd'hui alors tous les
départements en France ne sont pas
concernés par l'élection on va voir la
carte des 38 départements métropolitains
et six collectivités d'outremè qui sont
renouvelé aujourd'hui vous le voyez en
bleu ciel il y a des territoires peut
peupler les territoires les plus ruraux
dans ces départements où on élit un ou
deux sénateurs c'est un scrutin à deux
tours un scrutin majoritaire et dans les
départements qui sont en bleu foncé
c'est un scrutin qui se tient toute la
journée un scrutin à la proportionnelle
un scrutin de liste et d'ailleurs ce
sont ces départements que l'on va
particulièrement scruter pourquoi
Alexandre et bien parce que ce sont ceux
qui renouvellent le plus de sénateurs on
pense par exemple à Paris où il y a 12
sièges qui sont en jeu mais également à
deux départements dans les haut de Fran
le Nord 11 sièges à pourvoir le pcalé 7
sièges et enfin on va surveiller
particulièrement trois autres
départements l'izer C sièges à pourvoir
la Moselle 5 sièges ou encore la Loire
Atlantique 5 sièges voilà Alexandre pour
les grands enjeux de cette élection qui
se tient aujourd'hui dans ces 38
départements métropolitains et six
territoires d'outrem merci beaucoup
Quentin alors pour analyser et débattre
de ces élections sénatoriales
j'accueille sur ce plateau Stéphane
Verner bonjour bonjour vous êtes
directeur de la rédaction du journal
Ouest France à Paris j'accueille
également Émilie zapalski bonjour
bonjour vous êtes communicante
fondatrice et directrice de l'agence
Émilie conseil Florent vadiot bonjour
bonjour vous êtes enseignant à Sciences
Po et président du sy tank l'éérie et
puis j'accueille sur ce plateau Bastien
François bonjour bonjour vous êtes
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'université parien Panthéon Sorbonne
Bastien François on commence et bien ce
scrutin sénatorial par une information
importante pour la première fois un
indépendantiste de Nouvelle-Calédonie va
entrer au Sénat alors c'est une
information effectivement très
importante même si évidemment l'élection
de
Nouvelle-Calédonie va pas être dupliquée
au niveau France entière en tout cas
dans les départements où il y a un
renouvellement oui alors c'est la
première fois qu'un indépendantiste
arrive au Sénat bon évidemment s'il faut
le saluer il y a quelque chose bon et
puis il y a aussi je dirais c'est
presque l'information qui va peut-être
l'emporter immédiatement euh dans dans
la dans dans le commentaire politique il
y a une ministre du gouvernement qui est
batue qui est battu extrêmement
sèchement ce qui
alors c'est toujours assez compliqué à
interpréter mais on on peut penser que
c'est pas s en rapport avec le processus
actuel de de de discussion sur l'avenir
institutionnel de la Calédonie et cetera
en tout cas là on a une défaite très
nette du camp
gouvernemental qui va avoir peut-être
des conséquences dans les semaines ou
les mois à venir sur la façon dont euh
le gouvernement français va poursuivre
ou construire sa négociation sur
l'avenir institutionnel de de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie Florent vot c'est un
premier coup dur cette défaite de la
ministre Sonia baquè pour Emmanuel
Macron oui c'est c'est un coup dur
politique effectivement puisque ça
augure mal en général quand des élus
territoriaux désavouent le gouvernement
en place c'est jamais bon signe surtout
que il y avait quand même un un terraro
de d'alliance qui était très favorable
et puis surtout d'un point de vu
strictement lié au processus calédonien
c'est une grande difficulté puisque
Sonia baquess avait été à la manœuvre
pour accélérer sur les négociations
entre les représentants calédoniens et
le gouvernement et qu'aujourd'hui elle
est un peu démonétisée et quelque part
c'est la stratégie du gouvernement et de
géralde Haran en particulier qui est
démonétisé sur ce point-là on verra quel
est la le caractère durable de cela mais
il y aura quand même un loup en
embuscade si j'ose dire c'est que Gérard
Larché lui est très attentif au sujet
néocalédonien il y a une révision
constitut in qui serait souhaité pour
justement permettre une modification du
titre 13 et donc je pense que au-delà de
l'épihénomène calédonien il va y avoir
des répercussions des des utilisations
politiques qui peuvent être à moyen
terme et qui seront sans doute
difficiles à gérer pour le gouvernement
Stéphane Vernet est-ce que Sonia baquz
peut rester au gouvernement on connait
la règle quand un ministre perd une
élection locale et bien la règle c'est
de sortir du gouvernement
alors c'est une règle puis enfin on a on
a vu par le passé que au cours des deux
quinquenas d'Emmanuel Macron il y avait
un certain nombre de règ ou d'habit qui
n'était pas respecté donc on va voir
c'était l'ancien monde après ouais c'est
l'ancien monde moi ce que je ce que je
trouve intéressant c'est par rapport à
votre petite introduction tout à l'heure
Alexandre vous disiez qu'un des enjeux
de ce scrutin c'était de savoir si la
majorité présidentielle allait réussir à
s'imposer au Sénat j'ai envie de vous
dire la question est vite répondu
j'exagère parce qu'on va voir comment
les choses vont se passer puis on sait
très bien que les le la situation dans
les outr mè toujours très
particulière c'est difficile de se tirer
des généralités Le le la
Nouvelle-Calédonie est encore plus
particulier cont tenu du contexte qui
vient d'être décrit donc on va voir mais
mais en terme de d'image et de de signal
c'est très fort et c'est pas du tout de
bonne augure pour la majorité
présidentielle Florent vot est-ce que ça
veut dire que cette défaite de la
ministre en Nouvelle Calédonie ça rend
plus difficile voir ça ça bloque les
négociations institutionnelles avec les
indépendantistes sur l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie non parce qu'elles
étaient déjà un point de difficulté
assez avancé ça ça montre que les relais
euh du gouvernement sur place se sont
considérablement étiolés et qui a une
autre stratégie en tout cas en terme de
négociation à mettre en œuvre peut-être
pas sur le débouché institutionnel mais
en tout cas sur la manière de discuter
il y a quelque chose à changer et c'est
en quelque sorte le désaveux des
notables qui se rendent à Paris pour
négocier et qui sont désavoués par leur
instance partidaire on le voit avec le
Parti indépendantiste qui a demandé la
suspension des discussions jusqu'au
congrès de son parti donc c'est une
manière je pense qui va obliger le
gouvernement à prendre en considération
un écosystème qui sort des grands
notables pour aller véritablement dans
la discussion émilieapel une réaction
oui j'ai l'impression que ça ça va être
un peu le le souci de cette journée
d'aujourd'hui he cette espèce de de
confiance qui a été rompu avec les élus
depuis longtemps ça date même du
précédent quinena avec un Emmanuel
Macron qui voilà qui est détourné un
petit peu des concertations on l'a vu
aussi récemment avec les émeutes même si
les élus ont été reçu he les maires ont
été reçus à l'Élysée les 200 en ma mais
il y a pas de suite quelque part sur
leur proposition il y a très peu de
prise en compte et probablement dans ces
sénatoriels ça va ressortir moi ce que
je trouve intéressant vous l'avez dit
Stéphane c'est que les outremires c'est
toujours un peu particulier c'est vrai
qu'on peut pas dupliquer ce qui se passe
là avec Sonia baquz avec ce qui peut se
passer en métropole mais simplement en
terme d'image c'est terrible on sent
bien qu'on a un Emmanuel Macron qui
intervient d'ailleurs ce soir qui veut
faire un petit peu diversion parce que
probablement les sénatoriales ne seront
pas très bonnes pour Renaissance ils y
vont en ordre dispersé avec le Modem
horizon chacun un petit peu avec ses
envies de conquête notamment horizon il
aurait aimé peut-être que ça passe un
peu inaperçu et manque de chance voilà
on commence avec cette terrible nouvelle
c'est une ministre qui est batue je je
pense que ça ça donne un ton un peu
particulier à ces sénatoriel allez on va
aller voir nos journalistes qui sont sur
le terrain on va retrouver Steve jourain
en direct de l'Hôtel de Ville de Paris à
Steve comment se profile cette bataille
parisienne des élections
sénatoriales c'est un dimanche pas comme
les autres he ici Alex dans cette
superbe salle des fêtes de l'hôtel de
ville de Paris mise à disposition de la
préfecture pour l'occasion alors les
grands électeurs se succèdent depuis ce
matin 8h30 ils vont déposer déposer leur
bulletin dans dans l'urnne il y a près
de 3000 grands électeurs ici ils élisent
les 12 sénateurs qui iront ce soir au
Sénat c'est tout simplement la
circonscription qui envoie le plus de
sénateurs c'est aussi une ambiance un
peu particulière depuis ce matin Alex il
faut dire une ambiance comme ça un peu
électrique c'est un scrustin très
politique très médiatique puisqu'on a vu
des figures comme Yannick jado l'ancien
candidat écologiste à la présidentielle
on a aussi pu apercevoir an dalgo qui
est allé voter la mère de Paris on a vu
également Rashid hadti la maire du 7e
arrondissement de Paris et puis
évidemment un enjeu très politique très
comptable puisque la gauche ici souhaite
et bien envoyer un nouveau sénateur un
sénateur supplémentaire au Sénat en
compte actuellement 7 elle espère en
faire entrer un 8e d'autant plus qu'elle
part unie socialiste écologiste
communistes partent ensemble ils
espèrent faire tous ensemble ce 8e
sénateur la droite ici et bien elle
espère limiter la casse elle a
actuellement quatre sénateurs à Paris
elle espère limiter la casse pourquoi et
bien parce que la droite part désunis il
y a trois listes dissidentes qui se font
face et puis un mot peut-être aussi de
la majorité présidentielle qui possède
un sénateur en la personne de Julien
Bargeton Julien Bargeton qui espère ici
conserver son siège mais ça va être très
très très compliqué c'est en tout cas ce
qu'on me dit ce qu'on me dit aussi
également Alex ce matin et bien c'est
que c'est évidemment le moment des
sénatorial le moment où se décide la
composition du Sénat pour les trois
prochaines années mais c'est aussi
peut-être le premier tour de la bataille
de Paris le premier tour en vue de la
succession éventuelle d'analgo pour 2026
la succession à la mairie de Paris merci
beaucoup Steve alors qu'on va voir et
bien toutes les listes de candidats aux
élections sénatoriales à Paris
aujourd'hui our'hui des listes de
candidats qui s'affichent sur votre
écran Stéphane Vernet une première
réaction notamment sur ce scrutin
parisien on voit une droite divisée en
trois listes c'est un échec pour Rachid
hadti de rassembler à la droite
parisienne bah effectivement c'est ou
effectivement c'est pas bon signe non
plus c'est voilà la capacité à
rassembler pour les sénatoriales il y a
quand même pas mal de choses qui se
jouent pour l'avenir aujourd'hui donc al
c'est un petit peu compliqué à à décoder
mais et puis on est très en avance par
rapport à d'autres scrutins mais
effectivement l'incapacité à avoir une
droite unie alors que vous avez une
union entre les socialistes les
communistes et les et et les Verts
montre que bah il y a oui ça peut ça
peut être ça peut être compliqué pour la
suite il faut attendre de voir comment
ça va se traduire sur Paris vous le vous
l'aviez dit en préambule c'est le c'est
le département où il y a le plus de
sénateur à à élir 12 12 sièges là on
parle de la possibilité pour la liste
uni
entre PS PC et ELV d'avoir
éventuellement 8 sénateurs il faut voir
si on sait jamais on n'est pas à l'abri
d'une surprise ça peut même être plus
que ça même si ça paraît improbable à ce
stade donc on va on va on va regarder
comment les équilibres se ce ce fond et
ce et ce refond et en fonction des
résultats je pense qu'il y aura un
certain nombre de de choses qui vont se
dessiner pour le pour l'avenir et pour
la suite effectivement btien François
vous êtes d'accord est-ce que c'est
l'élection municipale à Paris en 2026
qui est déjà en train de se
jouer pour partie je dirais ça se joue
plus à droite et à Renaissance que à
gauche parce que à gauche il y a une
stratégie d'union de la gauche qui est
pas simplement à Paris bon qui a cette
particularité qu'elle élimine elle
fi donc alors peut-être la gauche aura
est vraisemblable qu'elle puisse avoir 8
sièges peut-être elle en aura un de plus
ce qui est moins très bien moins sûr
mais en tout cas l'arrivée à l'arrivée
ça sera un petit peu enfin ça sera pas
très simple à décrypter en en terme
d'équilibre des forces de gauche au sein
de Paris en revanche à droite là ça va
être très intéressant de regarder les
effets de la division et puis si
Renaissance perd son sénateur parisien
ça voudra dire quand même quelque chose
de très important d'autant plus que on
se souvient des scores quand même à
Paris de législativ de de de des
candidats macronistes qui faisaient des
scorss très importants donc là s'il
n'avait pas de sénateur ça voudrait dire
effectivement quelque chose et je pense
que alors il est bien trop tôt pour le
dire hein on aura les résultats que en
début de soirée hein mais là ça pourrait
être décrit vraiment là aussi comme un
enfin une défaite importante pour le
casamp pour le camp présidentiel Florent
vadiot cette union de la gauche à Paris
entre les socialistes écologistes
communistes qui reflèteent justement la
majorité municipale c'est une sorte de
victoire d' dalgo face aux insoumis qui
ne sont pas dans cette union en tout cas
c'est la victoire d'anidalgo qui dès le
dès cette première étape j'allais dire
ce premier tour des municipales non cet
avant premier tour des municipales a
montré que là où elle avait eu des
difficultés à rassembler au premier tour
des municipales cette fois-ci les
différents partenaires de gauche bien la
question ne se pose pas après il y a un
tel poid de la logique du majoritaire du
sortant que il y avait pas vraiment de
salut hors union de de la gauche sur ce
point-là en revanche il y a cette ce
message d'union puis il y a un message
de désunion qui à mon avis érinte la
l'image de Rachid hadti comme candidate
naturelle des droites à Paris parce
qu'en réalité elle n'a pas su rassembler
la famille des droites mais c'est pas
forcément si néfaste que ça parce que ça
obligera le camp présidentiel et la
droite à peut-être se parler pour la
suite donc méfions-nous des victoires à
la pyus ce soir à l'hôtel de vine Émilie
zapski vous croyez à une future alliance
locale à Paris entre droite et
Renaissance en tout cas on sait qu'au
niveau national c'est quand même
compliqué à l'Assemblée c'est difficile
he les alliances entre droite et et
Renaissance donc c'est pas gagné mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a quelque chose à
saisir donc probablement le l'enjeu
l'enjeu fera qu'il y aura peut-être des
alliances possibles moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est à gauche ce qui se
passe puisque en effet comme vous l'avez
dit c'est une union mais des socialistes
des écologistes et des communistes h LFI
qui n'a pas de de sénateur donc on voit
en miroir par rapport à ce qui se
passait à l'Assemblée nationale quelque
chose de complètement différent on n
plus sous la houlette nu es hein et on n
plus dans cet environnement très
brouillant qu'il y a à l'Assemblée
nationale et ça c'est intéressant de
voir cette gauche s'organiser ou se
réorganiser hors son extrême gauche et
de voir comment elle peut avancer dans
ce Sénat qui compte de plus en plus he
puisque la droite finalement ça aide
Emmanuel Macron à avancer alors qu'il
n'a pas la la majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée donc je trouve que c'est
intéressant de voir comment ils vont
pouvoir agir c'est un peu nouveau par
rapport aux législatives 2022 d'avancer
en LFI de ne pas se faire se marquer
nupes il y a aussi cet élément nouveau
de Yannick Jad qui essaie aussi d'avoir
son son petit poste de sénateur on lui
donne beaucoup de de d'ambition sur
Paris aussi donc voilà il y a des choses
qui qui se tram qui sont très
différentes par rapport à ce qui se
passe à l'Assemblée nationale et
d'ailleurs on pourrait dire la droite
c'est pareil hein il y a des désunions
là alors que finalement il y a pas mal
de choses qui se passent à l'Assemblée
donc c'est c'est intéressant Stéphane
Vernet vous direz aussi que ces
alliances peut-être un petit peu à
l'ancienne entre socialiste écologiste
et communiste c'est un pied de nez qui
est fait à l'alliance de laanupe à
l'Assemblée nationale
B moi je pense je pense qu'elle est
aussi dictée par le par une par le par
le réalisme c'est-à-dire que on sait
très bien qu'il y a pas de grand il y a
pas de grands électeurs France insoumise
donc donc la demande de la France
insoumise c'était de faire partie de
l'alliance pour pouvoir espérer avoir
quelques quelques sénateurs le ce ce ce
ce refus est un camoufl mais moi je
pense qu'il est dicté par l'idée que en
fait à 3 plutôt qu'à qu ils ont beaucoup
plus de chance ou plus de chance
potentiellement de d'avoir des sièges
est-ce que ça remet la question c'est
est-ce que ça remet en cause la suite
vous avez un un olivier fort qui dit que
c'est pas parce qu'il y a pas d'alliance
pour les sénatoriales ou les européennes
qui on aura pas pour les municipales ou
pour la présidentielle vous avez un vous
avez un Fabien Roussel qui se positionne
tout à fait différemment mais qui a
d'autres objectifs pour le parti
communiste sans doute qu'on en reparlera
au cours de de ce plateau chacun chacun
joue sa partition et vous avez une
France insoumise qui est
particulièrement agacée et qui le fait
savoir et qui met la pression sur ses
partenaires à travers l'expression de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon notamment mais je je
trouve que on est on est on est
aussi sur une scène politique et
médiatique où chacun s'exprime c'est une
façon de négocier et de négocier en
mettant une pression publique à travers
le le verbe euh moi ce que je vois
surtout c'est c'est que les résultats
encore une fois aujourd'hui auront leur
importance dans la suite de ces
négociations et de ces gesticulations
tout n'est pas perdu pour laanupes même
si c'est très compliqué puisque les
intérêts des uns et des autres ne sont
pas toujours convergents Florent vadiot
finalement il y a des alliances au sein
de la gauche à géométrie variable en
fonction du contexte électoral et donc
sur ces sénatoriales et bien l'alliance
de laanupes ça ne fonctionne pas plutôt
que de géométrie variable moi je
parlerai de chronologie variable parce
que les élections sénatoriales sont la
résultante des municipales et des
départementales où il y a pas eu
d'alliance entre il y a pas eu une
protonupes en quelque sorte donc c'est
la fin de cycle de de ce de ce de ces
élections là donc ça veut dire ça
n'obert pas un autre cycle pour des
municipales pour des départementales si
les partenaires parvenaient à se mettre
d'accord après c'est juste la vie
nationale de laanupe qui aura une
incidence sur les cycles à venir allez
on va retrouver Quentin Calmet qui est
dans notre cellule résultat Quentin quel
résultat de ces élections sénatoriales
vous avez pour le moment et bien
effectivement on le disait dès MIDH et
dem0i mais la Nouvelle Calédonie a déjà
terminé de voter pour les deux tours et
on le disait c'est une information
importante mais la secrétaire d'État à
la citoyenneté Sonia bques soutenu par
la majorité présidentielle est battu
dans ce territoire d'outrem les deux
sénateurs élus sont George naturel
divers droite qui est un maire loy
aliste et autre fait marquant c'est
l'élection de Robert xoui qui fait son
entrée à la Chambre haute une première
pour un élu indépendantiste nous avons
d'autres résultats qui nous sont
parvenus depuis ce Deidi et demi en
loszer où l'on a un siège à pourvoir la
socialiste membre du groupe RDSE Guilen
Pentel est réélu dès le premier tour et
autre information confirmé également en
Haute Loire dès le premier tour les
sortants Olivier sigolotti ainsi que
Laur duup plomb sont également réélus
autre information mais cette fois-ci au
conditionnel le maire PS de cor serait
élu dès le premier tour effectivement
dans cette circonscription voilà pour
les premiers résultats qui nous
parviennent au fur et à mesure de cette
matinée Alexandre et Quentin d'ailleurs
vous donnez les résultats de
départements où les sénateurs sont élus
au scrutin majoritaire à de Tours
exactement car dans les départements les
plus ruraux les moins peuplés ceux où on
élit un ou deux sénateurs il y a
effectivement deux tours d'élection un
premier tour le matin cela concerne 34
sénateurs 14 départements quatre
collectivités d'utrem c'est ainsi 20 %
des sièges à pourvoir et dans ces
départements il y a effectivement deux
tours le premier qui se joue entre 8h30
et 11h il peut y avoir des sénateurs qui
sont réélus à ce moment-là s'ils font
plus de la majorité absolue des scrutins
ainsi que 1/4 des suffrages exprimés
tandis que et bien dans les autres
départements et bien le scrutin se tient
sur toute la journée mais donc
effectivement ce sont des départements
où on va avoir deux tours et donc des
résultats dès la fin du premier tour
Alexandre merci beaucoup Quentin
justement Bastien François peut-être un
petit mot sur ce mode de scrutin des
sénatorial qui est un petit peu
particulier c'est un mode de scrutin
hybride oui alors je c'est un sujet
assez compliqué je sais pas jusqu'à quel
niveau de de précision vous voulez DESC
explique nos télpectateurs euh peut-être
qu'on va commencer par le corps
électoral c'estàd qui est-ce qui élit
les sénateurs donc les les sénateurs
sont élus par les députés du département
par les sénateurs du département et puis
le reste des électeurs l'essentiel c'est
des élus locaux hein des conseillers
départementaux des conseillers régionaux
en tout cas pour la fraction de ceux qui
sont élus dans ce département puisque
vous savez que les conseillers régionaux
sont élus dans plusieurs
départements et puis des délégués des
conseils municipaux euh alors ça le
nombre de délégués de conseils
municipaux varie selon la taille des des
des communes hein dans les toutes
petites communes il y a un délégué c'est
généralement le maire puis après il y a
d'autres conseillers municipaux puis il
y a à partir de de 30000 habitants on va
chercher des
délégués municipaux qui sont choisis par
le conseil municipal dans les parmi les
électeurs ou les inscrit les électrices
inscrites sur sur le sur dans le
département
euh donc ça ça a toute une série
d'effets parce qu'il y a une
surreprésentation
des communes petites ou moyennes plutôt
rurales et cetera bien mais ça a aussi
des effets liés au fait que pour pouvoir
avoir une chance d'être élu il faut être
avoir un parti des candidats qui sont
déjà très bien implantés
territorialement he c'est que c'est
c'est des élus locaux qui élisent en
fait des d'autres élus locaux ou des
gens qui qui ont eu pas dans le passé
des mandats locaux importants bon et ça
par exemple ça a des pour revenir à la
disc qu'on avait sur Paris tout à
l'heure mais en l'élargissant en plan
national bon mais ça veut dire qu'il y a
un certain nombre de partis qui sont
pourtant dominants à l'Assemblée
nationale bon le RN Renaissance LFI qui
alors dans le cas du RN aura peut-être
on va y revenir c'est un des enjeux du
scrutin on parler quelques élus mais bon
le
F n en aura pas et Renaissance aura sans
doute un groupe en tout cas pas à la
mesure de son importance bon parce que
là les les sénatoriales enregistrent en
réalité les résult d' a 3 ans c'est pas
le rapport de force d'aujourd'hui même
s'il y a des éléments du rapport de
force d'aujourd'hui peut-être on y
reviendra
mais les sénatoriales enregistrent les
résultats des élections municipales de
2020 et et donc il zapelski finalement
ces élection sénatorial c'est un scrutin
national mais qui va nous donner et bien
une vision des rapports de forces
politiques locaux oui ça c'est
intéressant parce que c'est vrai que
c'est une vision qu'on a du mal à faire
intervenir justement dans la vie
politique euh publ quelque part les
gilets jaunes se sont rappelés aux
oreilles d'Emmanuel Macron avec cette
vision très territoire on appelle ça
territoire on dit plus la province c'est
les territoires c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans les dans les villes
dans les villages et c'est vrai que les
sénatorials sont un peu la
représentation de ça mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est en terme d'image le
Sénat ça a changé l'image c'est vrai que
c'est des élections assez compliquées
c'est vrai qu'auaravant le Sénat bah
onvoyait finalement il donnit un petit
peu leurs recommandations sur les
projets de loi qui étaient tout
redétricoter et voter à l'Assemblée
nationale depuis qu'Emmanuel Macron
depuis que Renaissance n'a pas la
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée il se
repose beaucoup sur le Sénat et
d'ailleurs on a vu des projets de loi et
on va en voir encore il y a eu les
énergies renouvelables il y a
l'immigration qui va arriver d'abord au
Sénat donc qui passe d'abord comme une
caisse de résonance pour la majorité au
Sénat modifier et ensuite à l'Assemblée
ça veut dire que le Sénat redevient un
petit peu revient au devant de la scène
et je pense que ça peut-être dans la
société enfin moi je laisse en tout cas
c'est ça prouve un petit peu plus ça
montre un petit peu plus la force du
Sénat avec cette représentation des
territoires ruraux ou péri urbain et
autre chose le Sénat a aussi acquis un
petit peu une image peut-être plus
active avec tout cette cette histoire de
contrôle qu'ils ont effectué il y a eu
un contrôle sur l'affaire benala le fond
Marianne plus récemment et quelque part
ça les fait ressortir comme voilà des
des acteurs publics très actifs sur ce
qui se passe dans la dans la vie
politique allez on va aller dans dans un
autre point chaud de ces élections
sénatoriales on va prendre la direction
du département du Nord avec Samia dechir
Samia dechir vous êtes en direct de la
préfecture de Lille où l'élection
sénatoriale cette année s'annonce très
serrée oui car il y a un nombre record
de listes on en compte 16 16 listes pour
11 sièges de sénateurs à pourvoir
forcément ça entraîne un éparpillement
des voix et ça rend cette élection
sénatoriale particulièrement incertaine
dans le département alors d'abord à
gauche on compte pas moins de six listes
dont bien sûr celle du sénateur sortant
Patrick canner qui est le président du
groupe socialiste au Sénat qu'on a vu
voter ce matin ici à la préfecture du
Nord quatre listes à droite et au
centre- droit dont celle d'un autre
sénateur sortant Marc Philippe d'bress
trois listes également chez les
indépendants et les membres de la
majorité présidentielle bref vous l'avez
compris il n'y a aucune alliance mais
beaucoup de divisions et ça ça pourrait
favoriser le rassemblement national le
candidat idat du RN Joshua auchard
espère faire un siège c'est possible il
faut dire que son parti a gagné des élus
dans plusieurs villes ici au derniers
municipal de 2020 or je rappelle que ce
sont essentiellement ces élus municipaux
he qui votent aux élections sénatoriales
mais ce n'est pas non plus gagneré
d'avance pour le rassemblement national
parce qu'il y a un autre candidat de
reconquête l'autre parti d'extrême
droite celui d'Éric Zemour qui pourrait
lui grignoter quelques voix or c'est
justement à quelques voix près que vont
se jouer ces élections sénatoriales très
serrées i dans le Nord eu merci beaucoup
Samia pour vos explications sur ce
scrutin des élections sénatoriales dans
le département du Nord et sur votre
écran vont s'afficher la totalité des
listes de candidats dans ces élections
sénatoriales dans le département du Nord
Samia Decher l' dit c'est un scrutin qui
va être serré car il y a 16 listes de
candidats dans ce département 16 listes
qui vont et bien se débartager pour
obtenir IR 11 sièges de sénateurs à
pourvoir dans pourvoir dans le
département du Nord c'estvan Vern une
réaction sur ce scrutin nordiste on a
parlé finalement des accords dans
certains départements comme à Paris
entre les différents partis de gauche
mais il peut y avoir aussi des divisions
là il y en a pas oui effectivement bon
alors 16 listes c'est beaucoup c'est un
département particulièrement intéressant
parce que c'est un département on peut
avoir un sénateur RN qui qui qui est qui
émerge on sait qu'il y aura priori il
peut y avoir des sénateurs erenes qui
qui qui qui prendront des sièges enfin
qui qui feront leur rentrée au Sénat à
l'issue de cette élection hein on parle
on parle on parle du Nord on parle on
parle de la Moselle vous allez y revenir
et d'autres départements il il y a
d'autres d'autres endroits à surveiller
l'ouise enfin bon bref on peut avoir des
surprises moi je pense que ce qui va
être intéressant d'une manière générale
ce sera aussi de regarder le nombre de
voix sur l'ensemble du scrutin qui
seront fait par des candidats et des
candidates du rassemblement national
parce que même s'ils ont pas de siège ou
très peu hein parce que le RN affiche
des ambitions enfin fait ses calculs en
espérant avoir 10 sièges 10 sièges
pourquoi c'est pour créer un groupe mais
ça n'arrivera pas ça peut se faire à la
marge mais par contre on peut avoir un
nombre de voix très important sur
l'ensemble du territoire et qui dira
aussi quelque chose de la la progression
du parti sur l'ensemble de de de la
France c'est pas parce qu'ils obtiennent
pas beaucoup de sièges aujourd'hui qui
peuvent pas avoir de de bons résultats
et après pour terminer dans les au
sénatorial il y a pas de il y a pas très
peu de surprise en fait on sait à peu
près quels sont les grands équilibres ce
qui va se passer mais quand même je vous
rappelle que pour le les
législatives Jordane Bardella ou Marine
Le Pen avant les dernières législatives
dans leur rêv les plus fous ils
imaginent qu'ils auraient 50 députés ils
en a eu 89 donc il y a aussi il y a il
peut y avoir aussi un de surprise
surtout avec des municipales où plus on
avance dans le temps plus on a des élus
qui se présent présente sans étiquette
mais sans étiquette ça veut pas dire
sans opinion et là il y a il peut y
avoir un un manque de lisibilité donc
encore une fois je pense que ce sera
vraiment intéressant de regarder
l'ensemble des voix qu'obtiendront les
candidats et des candidates
rassemblement national sur l'ensemble de
l'élection et voir également si ça peut
être le produit aussi d'un travail de
terrain qui sont faits dans les
circonscriptions par leurs nouveaux
députés donc ça ça je pense que même
s'il y a pas je me répète mais même s'il
y a pas beaucoup de sénateurs élus je
pense que ça va être très intéress
de regarder dans le détail ce scrutin du
côté du rassemblement national Florent
Vadi on le voit avec l'exemple du
département du Nord c'est aussi la
division des autres liste que ça soit à
gauche ou à droite qui peut favoriser et
bien le rassemblement national dans ce
scrutin alors oui effectivement la
division est un accélérateur après il
n'est pas certain qu'il n'y aurait pas
eu des voies fortes porté au Front
national hors division c'est les les
réalités locales sont quand même très
prégante très importante mais le le le
Nord montre que on est dans la politique
gribouille c'est que tout le monde a
voulu en jouant sur un scrutin de liste
en réalité faire etlire la tête de liste
et donc on est en fait au au au qui plus
faible gagne et donc c'est une véritable
hostilité de de de de baronier de
clientélisme qui se qui se heurte et
c'est ça le vrai drame des élection
sénatorial parfois c'est lorsqu'on joue
avec le scrutin contre une logique qui
pourrait permettre de bâtir des
majorités am appppel qui on peut tomber
dans l'éparpillement dans ce scrutin
proportionnel oui mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est aussi la montée du
rassemblement national alors c'est
intéressant parce que ça tombe à un
moment où le Conseil d'État a tranché
c'était une demande du rassemblement
national de de de ne plus être
catégoriser extrême droite au niveau de
de l'Assemblée et le Conseil d'État a
tranché en disant si c'est bien parti
d'extrême droite il y a pas il y a pas
de problème et ça ne vous portera pas
préjudice donc c'est quand même
intéressant on peut donc parler de parti
d'extrême droite mais simplement oui on
voit bien une progression et ce que
disait Stéphane c'est vrai on a eu le
cas pour les régionales hein c'est
pareil on disait ah ils vont gagner
peut-être une région on en a beaucoup
beaucoup parler donc il y a une espèce
de voilà de de de main mise sur ces
élections de toute façon ça va se faire
avec eux et globalement si imaginons
donc ils avaient deux sénateurs l'un qui
est parti chez reconquête l'autre qui a
préféré la mairie de freéjus donc pas de
sénateur on a 88 députés à l'Assemblée
nationale bon ils étaient 89 au départ
il y en a 88 imaginez s'il y en avait
même un ou deux sénateurs on rentre dans
un autre monde on rentre dans un monde
où l'extrême droite je me fais le
plaisir de de d'utiliser l'expression
est bien présente que ce soit au niveau
du Sénat ou au niveau de l'Assemblée
nationale il me semble que ça ça serait
pas un camouflé mais c'est quand même
voilà ça aura marqué quand même ses
quinena et ses présidences d'Emmanuel
Macron avec cette idée de de de
brouiller un petit peu la gauche- droite
et ben on se retrouve quand même avec le
rassemblement national en tout cas déjà
très très présent dans une assemblée
avec le risque dans une seconde et même
si c'est pas le cas comme disait
Stéphane voilà il progresse dans la vie
publique que ça soit nationale ou ou
local Bastien François oui alors d'abord
sur l'éparpillement euh cette élection
en tout cas pour pour la partie de cette
élection qui se passe à la
proportionnelle euh elle favorise
l'éparpillement et d'ailleurs c'est
c'est une des rares élections où on peut
gagner à l'éparpillement et c'est
d'ailleurs une technique utilisée
souvent pour éliminer les femmes hein
dans le même camp vous mettez plusieurs
têtes de liste hommes comme les listes
doivent être paritair les femmes en sont
en deux il y a que la tête de List qui
gagne c'est pour ça que le Sénat en
dépit d'un mode de SCR improportionnel
et moins féminisé que l'Assemblée
nationale qui a pourtant un mode de
scrutin qui est qui ne favorise pas la
parité ça c'était sur l'éparpillement
sur le RN je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous ça va être extrêmement
intéressant même s'ils ont pas de
sénateur de regarder qui a élu qui les a
enfin le nombre de voix qu'ils ont
pourquoi on s on s'est un petit peu
trompé lorsqu'on a au moment du
Commentaire des élections législatives
évidemment on était surpris c'était
énorme et ce et Tera et on les a traité
comme des nouveaux entrants en politique
en réalité si vous prenez leur CV à
chacun de ces députés la plupart sont
implantés et depuis longtemps localement
ils ont des petits mandats parfois ils
ont échoué de nombreuses fois des
élections ça veut dire qu'ils sont sur
le terrain bon là si le RN devait faire
devait avoir beaucoup de voix sans avoir
de siège ça voudrait dire que vraiment
il a avancer
significativement dans son implantation
territoriale et ça voudrait dire aussi
que il y a une petite digue qu' aurait
lâché ce que ce que constate les
spécialistes la carte électorale c'est
que les les élus divers droit sans
étiquette généralement ne vouleit pas
voter pour des élus RN parce que ben ça
c'est le Sénat le Sénat voilà ne vote
pas pour enfin les électeurs les grands
électeurs au Sénat ne votent pas pour la
fraction la plus à droite de la droite
et la fraction la plus à gauche de la
gauche bon ça c'est quelque chose
d'historique bon là si on voyait ces
élus locaux sans étiquette des petits
des petites communes et cetera donner
des voix au Front national enfin au RN
pardon ça voudrait dire effectivement
qu'on est dans quelque chose qui s'est
véritablement implanté localement et si
vous ajoutez à ça le fait que le RN à la
sortie de cette enfin de cette
législature à l'Assemblée nationale va
sortir beaucoup plus fort avec de
l'expérience avec des centaines de
collaborateurs parlementaires formés et
bien vous aurez à la sortie c'est-à-dire
à avant la prochaine élection
présidentielle vous aurez un RN qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec le RN d'avant la
précédente présidentielle avec des gens
qui sont implantés sur le terrain qui
font des scorses dans des endroits où il
faisaient jamais de score et c'est pour
ça que je crois qu'un des enjeux de
cette élection sans suspense c'est quand
même d'aller effectivement regarder
peut-être l'enjeu principal c'est
d'aller regarder les scores du RN même s
n'obtient pas il n'obtiendra jamais
enfin un groupe un groupeti tiendra pas
on le rappelle pour avoir un groupe
politique au Sénat il faut au moins 10
sénateur sénateurs et là dans les
prévisions pour le moment les plus
favorables pour le moment encore une
fois il y a des surprises hein ça serait
quatre hein donc voilà on en est loin on
continuera on continuera à parler de cet
enjeu politique pour le rassemblement
national dans ces élections sénatoriales
puisqu'on ira retrouver Mathias Arz en
Mosel mais d'abord on va retrouver
Quentin Calmet Quentin qui a de nouveaux
résultats sur ces élections sénatoriales
et Quentin on connaît maintenant les
cinq premiers sénateurs et voilà sur les
170 qui sont renouvelés aujourd'hui mais
d'abord cette information importante
puisque un membre du gouvernement a été
battu lors de ces sénatoriales en
Nouvelle-Calédonie où l'élection est
déjà terminée avec le décalage horaire
il s'agit de Sonia baques secrétaire
d'État à la citoyenneté en
Nouvelle-Calédonie deux sénateurs sont
élus on parle de George naturel qui est
un sénateur maintenant divers droite qui
est loyaliste autre fait marquant
l'entrée à la Chambre haute de Robert
Gou ioui qui est un le deuxème élu lors
de cette sénatorielle et qui est un élu
indépendantiste qui va faire son entrée
c'est une première au Sénat en lozer on
peut également confirmer l'élection la
réélection de Guilen Pantel une élu
socialiste membre du groupe RD RDSE he
ce groupe à majorité de radicaux ici au
Sénat dans ce département qui
renouvelait un siège autre résultat
confirmé définitif puisque les deux
sénateurs ont fait plus de 70 % les deux
sortants en haute loi sont réélu il
s'agit d'Olivier sigigolotti un élu
centriste ainsi que Laurent Duplomb un
sénateur les républicains spécialisé sur
les questions d'agriculture enfin je
voulais terminer avec le Lot etgaron où
à agin on renouvelle deux postes de
sénateur et là et bien il n'y a personne
qui sort son épingle du jeu au premier
tour les 10 listes peuvent se maintenir
au second tour et on voit les trois
premier arrivés en tête Christine
monfantisa la sénatrice LR sortante qui
fait 42 % des voix Michel
mass qui est un candidat divivers gauche
qui réalise près de 40 % des voix et
enfin le sortant centriste Jean-Pierre
Moga qui fait 29 % des voix tout va se
jouer au second tour qui se tient entre
15h30 et 17h30 si certains se
maintiennent on pourra avoir un jeu
comme cela entre qui se maintient et qui
retire sa liste tout va se jouer cet
après-midi dans le département du
lotgaron voilà pour les premiers
résultats qu'on pouvait vous donner
Alexandre merci beaucoup Quentin alors
on a parlé du rassemblement national des
enjeux politiques pour le par de Marine
Le Pen je voudrais qu'on parle du groupe
politique majoritaire ici à la Haute
Assemblée le groupe des Républicains
Florent vadiillot c'est un scrutin qui
s'annonce plutôt confortable pour la
droite il y a une très belle phrase de
de Guy Carcasson qui avait parfois de de
très fortes fulgurance c'est quand la
gauche perd les élections elle perd tout
quand la droite perd les élections elle
garde le Sénat et de fait on se rend
compte que quel que soit l'état
électoral des républicains sur les
autres scrutins globalement il sont pas
menacés au Sénat et en réalité ils ils
ont peur dans les prévisions les plus
pessimistes de perdre un siège et pour
les plus optimiste d'en gagner jusqu'à 4
donc en réalité le la question se pose
moins sur l'état de la majorité on peut
avoir des variations même plus
importante mais ça ça reste quand même
l'épur du trait c'est ensuite derrière
l'élection de Gérard Larché qui lui elle
aussi est quasiment acquise mais la
répartition des postes qui n'est pas
neutre et et notamment dans les futurs
successeurs de Gérard rché car certains
se préparent c'est le cas par exemple de
Philippe B qui s'il arrive à faire le
grand chlem dans son département dans la
Manche et bien il sera bien placé pour
pour montrer qu'il est la fierté de la
droite républicaine donc voilà je pense
que c'est plutôt des signaux euh au sein
des républicains qui seront envoyés plus
qu' un un mouvement de de de plaque ce
soir oui il y a quand même des enjeux au
sein de la formation des républicains
Stéphane Vernet finalement on peut avoir
l'impression d'un point de vue national
que le parti les républicains est un
parti très affaibli notamment après les
défaites à la présidentielle le nombre
de députés qui diminue mais le fait est
qu'il reste majoritaire au Sénat et
qu'ils sont bien implanté localement
alors très majoritaire et très bien
implanté localement oui bien sûr
en plus sur les sénatoriales il y a
quand même une une inertie très forte vu
la la nature même des des élections donc
donc là je pense qu'il y aura très peu
de surprise en plus c'est un des un des
groupes qui est le moins soumis à
renouvellement en fait pu que 65 sièges
à renouveler sur 145 en proportion les
autres il sont tous au moins au moins
renouvelabl pour moitié ou presque euh à
l'exception fait des vertes puisque les
vertes ont que quatre sièges
renouvelables sur 12 donc c'est ceux qui
sont les moins les moins soumis à à à
renouvellement mais ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que
euh effectivement il est plus que très
probable que cette élection confirme une
grande stabilité de cette de cette de
cette majorité et il y a assez peu de
doute sur le l'élection du futur
président du du du Sénat oui c'est ça va
pas se jouer là alors qu'on aurait pu se
dire que euh parce que vous parlez de de
la baisse des des élus LR dans dans le
temps d'accord mais il y a il y a eu
aussi toute la problématique du de la
séquence réforme des retraites et le le
le jeu un peu complexe pour ne pas dire
trouble des républicains au sein de
cette réforme on pourrait se dire que ça
pourrait se traduire par une espèce
d'impopularité on les a vu descendre
dans les dans les sondages et cetera
auprès du du grand public mais le grand
public ce ne sont pas les grands
électeurs donc euh donc je pense que
c'est ça ne se traduira pas par par un
recul du nombre de sièges euh des
républicains au au Sénat en tout cas pas
maintenant peut-être plus tard encore
une fois c'est tout tout est question
d'inertie émilieapsi comment vous voyez
cet enjeu pour la droite dans ces
sénatorial c'est un peu le moment de
gloire parce que c'est vrai que le Sénat
gerérard arché on voit bien qu'il pèse
énormément euh de ce côté-là mais c'est
vrai que si on voit au niveau national
c'est quand même assez catastrophique
parce que pour l'instant il y a pas de
figure naturelle qui est déterminé on
entend beaucoup on entend des noms
Laurent voquet mais il y a rien
d'évident et puis surtout en terme
d'idée il y a rien qui différencie les
républicains ils sont coincés entre le
rassemblement national à l'extrême
droite et de l'autre côté par la
politique d'Emmanuel Macron donc oui
forcément c'est un moment important pour
eux au Sénat mais c'est très limité ils
sont dans un terrain de jeu qui est
vraiment très très limité alors
évidemment qu' vont profiter de ce
moment-là et Gérard Larché en premier
lieu si notamment il est réélu et qui
redevient président donc c'est troisème
homme c'est ça de l'État 2e ou 3e 3e
donc c'est assez important mais c'est
comme une coquille vide quelque part
c'est comme un un faux semblant puisque
ça n'a ça n'a pas lieu d'être au niveau
national ils n'arrivent pas à retrouver
leur deuxième souffle vraiment ils sont
perdus là-dessus et je trouve que c'est
intéressant parce que on voit bien comme
vous l'avez dit que c'est des partis et
la gauche aussi qui sont très
représentés localement qui sont très
planté localement qui ont l'oreille on
entendait tout à l'heure une des
personnalités qui est réélu sénateur sur
l'agriculture donc des thématiques qui
qui devrait être au devant de la scène
et malheureusement au niveau national on
a plutôt des partis qui sont un peu
éloigné de tout ça et globalement ça
présage pas vraiment des choses très
très bonnes sur bah l'ambiance générale
parce que on sent qu'il y a une partie
de la population qui se sent pas
vraiment représenté qui se sentirai
peut-être représentés au Sénat ou à
l'Assemblée nationale mais qui se sont
pas représentés dans les figure
nationale et ça il y a un espèce de
décrochage qui risque d'être un peu un
peu fort au fur à mesure Bastien
François comment on explique que on a
cette formation de droite les
républicains qui est plutôt forte
localement ça se traduit au Sénat et qui
est plutôt faible nationalement mais
c'est il y a pas que le il y a pas que
LR il y a le Parti socialiste aussi mais
c'est la la l' vous le voyez s'il suffit
de comparer le Sénat et et l'Assemblée
nationale vous voyez très bien la la
différence du corps électoral bon euh
les partis dominants à l'Assemblée
nationale comme je disais tout à l'heure
c'est Renaissance le RN et lesfi et bien
RN pratiquement pas au Sénat et les
filles en a pas et Renaissance à un tout
petit groupe enfin par rapport en tout
cas au score de son candidat et au score
législative bon
euh donc et à l'inverse à l'inverse au
Sénat vous avez les alors on pourrait
parler ancien monde hein on a les partis
de l'Ancien Monde qui pourquoi parce
qu'ils sont implantés depuis très
longtemp dans dans le territoire il est
pas sûr d'ailleurs que les sénateurs LR
soient exactement les mêmes que les
députés LR hein dans leur carrière dans
leur rapport à la politique et cetera
dans la façon de faire la politique bon
alors après donc voilà donc vous avez un
groupe LR qui va rester stable qui va
continuer et qui va jouer un rôle très
important parce que quand même en
l'absence de
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée nationale
on passe par ce groupe LR qui est celui
par lequel on est obligé de passer bon
et son rôle son rôle va peut-être varier
un petit peu il va rester dominant là
dans d'ici la prochaine présidentielle
s'il y a pas évidemment de solution de
l'Assemblée nationale ce qui va
peut-être un petit peu bouger c'est
l'escore des centristes et ce qui se
passe au sein de renaissance he
c'est-à-dire effectivement si Édouard
philiip pouvait créer un groupe horizon
au sein de la majorité présidentielle
enfin de la minorité présidentielle du
Sénat euh je rappelle quand même que on
voit que Édouard Philippe dit très
clairement qu'il est de droite que euh
que le président de l'archer dit que bah
il est de la même famille donc il y a y
a un jeu qui il y a quelque chose qui
est en train de se jouer à droite pour
rappelle qu'il y a déjà un groupe les
indépendants au Sénat avec des sénateurs
qui sont membres du parti horizon un
groupe qui fait à la fois partie de la
majorité sénatorial et qui est
constructif avec le gouvernement voilà
donc il va y avoir et puis il va y avoir
aussi une petite tension on la connaît
déjà il y a une tension entre la droite
et le centre au au Sénat entre une
fraction disons extrêmement critique qui
veut pas contre euh contre la MA enfin
contre les macronistes qui existe aussi
évidemment à l'Assemblée nationale et
une partie plus prête à négocier et et
d'ailleurs qui qui fait des qui a des
gains importants si vous regardez la
dernière année à l'Assemblée nationale
souvent vous savez on dit c'est le
dernier mot à l'Assemblée nationale en
réalité 80 % des amendements votés par
le Sénat ont été repris par l'Assemblée
nationale ça ça n'arrivait jamais avant
et si vous prenez les commissions mixtes
paritaires c'est le moment où
l'Assemblée nationale Sénat doivent se
mettre d'accord sur un texte euh dans
pour la partie Sénat euh euh bah c'est
la droite et le centre qui est dominant
donc ils sont en position le Sénat est
quand même là actuellement en position
d'imposer énormément de choses dans dans
l'ensemble de la production législative
française et justement on parlera de ces
relations entre le Sénat et l'exécutif
et Emmanuel Macron des relations qui ont
changer notamment depuis 2022 on va se
rendre en Mosel on va retrou trouver
Mathias Araz qui est en direct de mes et
Mathias et bien ce département de Mosel
il est notamment ciblé par le
rassemblement national dans ces
sénatorial absolument Alexandre un
département sur lequel le RN a des vues
et pour cause avec plusieurs maires avec
plusieurs députés avec plusieurs
conseillers régionaux le parti d'extrême
droite compte aussi sur le fait que
Jean-Louis Masson un sénateur sortant
bien implanté localement ayant rejoint
Marine Le Pen en 2021 ne se représ pas
le RN a donc investi Michel Rambourg
maire de vancour une petite commune de
76 habitants qui se veut donc le
candidat des campagnes contre les
métropoles ce qui est certain Alexandre
c'est que ce soir le paysage sénatorial
ici en Moselle aura un tout autre visage
comme je vous le disais Jean-Louis maçon
ne se représente pas tout comme
Jean-Marc todchini sénateur socialiste
sortant ancien ministre qui a donc
décidé de passer la main alors des
cartes rebattues qui forcément créent de
l'espoir au sur la ligne de départ il y
a 13 listes aujourd'hui ici en Moselle
avec à l'arrivée seulement euh cinq
sièges à faire alors parmi les listes
que l'on peut citer qui peuvent avoir
des espoirs ou en tout cas les nourrir
on peut citer celle de Jean-Marie mon
apparentée euh de l'Union centriste qui
a donc décidé cette année de partir main
dans la main avec Catherine belritielle
elle est bien investie par les
républicains une liste estampillée
majorité sénatoriale qui ambitionne de
faire à minima de sièges ce soir à
droite toujours il y a une autre
sortante Christine Herzog ancienne
colissière de Jean-Louis Masson qui elle
a décidé de faire campagne sur ses
différences avec son ancien allié en
politique à gauche le premier fédéral
socialiste Michael Weber à dououbé par
Jean-Marc todeschin a réussi à raller
une partie des communistes du
département mais il n'a pas réussi à
faire l'union totale avec les vers ou
encore la France insoumise la France
insoumise qui présentera d'ailleurs une
liste lors de ces sénatoriales dans le
département parmi les outsiders on peut
également citer Anne boucher je vous
entendais parler des candidats horizon
elle était candidate aux dernières
élections législatives elle n'avait pas
réussi à se faire élire elle est donc
candidate aujourd'hui avec cette
bannière horon elle a d'ailleurs reçu le
soutien d'Édouard Philippe c'était jeudi
à sargemine ou encore autre outsider
duquel on peut parler bien c'est Jérémy
Aldrin c'était un candidat aux élections
municipales ici à mes en 2020 il avait
fait un très bon score et il peut il
peut compter sur des soutiens de de poid
en la personne notamment de Marie José
Zimmerman ancienne député du département
bref une éle
ouverte ici en Moselle avec de
nombreuses inconnus et pour cause comme
je vous le disais il y a de nombreuses
listes notamment à droite on en compte
neuf avec un risque Alexandre et bien
c'est que il y ait une dispersion des
voix ici merci beaucoup Mathias Arz en
direct de mes Stéphane Vernet on
continue à à parler du parti les
républicains majoritaires ici au Sénat
les républicains au Sénat sont peut-être
un petit peu différents dans leur style
dans leur choix que les républicains à
l'Assemblée
nationale je crois qu' je crois qu'on
l'a vu de manière assez éclatante ces
derniers ces derniers mois oui
effectivement mais alors il y a toujours
eu il y a toujours eu un petit yatus
entre les entre les entre les deux
groupe euh qui peut tenir à plein de
plein de choses
euh simplement peut-être le le le le le
rapport aux électeurs là le le le mode
de scrutin on a aussi un groupe les
républicains à l'assemblée qui qui
compte tenu du contexte des dernières
législatives est persuadé que en fait
les chacun des puté élu c'est persuadé
qu'il a été élu sur son nom et son nom
propre et et donc les les les le groupe
se sent moins redevable vis-à-vis du
parti et à su s' franchir de manière
assez spectaculaire des des des
consignes qui qui étaient donné et oui
pour répondre à votre question donc les
les les il y a cette ces différen qui
existent entre les entre les deux
groupes qui se sont
accusés à l'occasion de la réforme des
des retraites et oui on a un
gouvernement qui en joue c'est-à-dire
que traditionnellement c'est ce qui
expliquait très bien Émilie tout à
l'heure c'est que traditionnellement en
fait ne viennent en première lecture au
Sénat que les textes qui concernent
directement le Sénat la ruralité
l'aménagement du territoire les
collectivités et cetera et que
aujourd'hui il y a une bascule qui s'est
faite c'est-à-dire que pour mettre un
petit coup de pression en difficulté les
républicains de l'Assemblée on choisit
de faire passer un certain nombre de
textes importants ou qui vont faire
débat d'abord au Sénat ou il y a une
capacité à créer des à produire du
consensus et un travail enfin voilà de
de à trouver des à trouver des points
d'accord qui manifestement est
supérieure aujourd'hui au Sénat par
rapport à l'assemblée pour ensuite
pouvoir dire au députés républicains de
l'Assemblée bah regardez vos homologues
du Sénat sont d'accord avec nous on
s'est mis d'accord avec eux on a trouvé
une voie de passage la logique voudrait
que vous suiviez leur trac on a vu que
dans la réforme des retraites c'est pas
ce qui s'était passé je ne suis pas sûr
que la recette soit une formule magique
et qu'on puisse décliner pour chaque
texte enfin on verra bien en tout cas
oui y a a c'est c'est à travers ces
différences de comportement qu'on voit
bien qu'il a qu' a que les deux groupes
ne sont pas en harmonie totale et et
encore une fois ça pose la question
aussi au-delà de ça de la capacité du
parti à avoir à avoir des représentants
discipliné qui suivent les consignes
pour l'instant ça marche pas comment on
explique qu'il autant divergence entre
le groupe les républicains au Sénat le
groupe les républicains à l'Assemblée
nationale alors qu'ils sont du même
parti d'abord il il y a une très grande
différence c'est que les députés à
l'Assemblée nationale ils ont
nécessairement été élus contre Emmanuel
Macron parce que ça a été très frontal
ils avaient des candidat face à eux il y
avait très peu de circonscriptions où il
y avait un désistement du camp
présidentiel en faveur des républicains
donc ceux qui sont élus ont un peu
l'idée qu'ils sont le dernier carré et
que ils doivent une grande partie de
leur malheur et de la der éliction dans
laquelle se trouve les républicains à
l'Assemblée nationale à Emmanuel Macron
et on le voit d'ailleurs sur la grande
intransigence d'Olivier marlex à discuté
avec le gouvernement sur le blocage
qu'il y a et puis ça n'est pas
véritablement le cas au Sénat puisque le
Sénat c'est finalement 2020 on peut
considérer que c'était compliqué mais
mais pas pas très frontal c'est
finalement la première élection où il va
y avoir des candidatures du camp
présidentiel contre des républicains
sortants et au demeurant au Sénat il y a
quand même au moins trois franches qui
se qui s'affronte moi je je mettrai en
avant celle de Bruno rotayo qui a
toujours été très intransigent et qu'on
on voit de plus en plus jouer sur la
droite du parti hein c'est éic il se
sotise pourrait-on dire il y a un
Philippe Bas qui a toujours été loup
voyant à la fois complaisant mais très
dur sur l'affaire benala on s'en
souvient et puis qui était le président
de la commission d'enquête du sén et
ancien président de la commission des
Lois du Sénat et puis il y a un Gérard
Larcher dont on a vu des signes
d'ouverture puis de fermeture sur la
révision constitutionnelle par exemple
et qui avait un peu une épée dans le dos
de la part de Bruno retaillot pour
éviter de discuter donc en fait il y a
une une grande différence Assemblée
nationale Sénat mais au sein du Sénat il
y a quand même des courants qui se qui
s'affrontent et c'est en cela que le
résultat de ce soir et notamment
l'avenir du camp présidentiel ce soir
c'est disparaî-il noyer dans d'autres
groupes et cetera aura un impact très
fort sur l'attitude du groupe les
républicains au Sénat vis-à-vis du
gouvernement Émilie zapski juste avant
de vous donner la parole on va retrouver
Quentin calm puisque Quentin vous avez
vous avez de nouveaux résultats oui tout
à fait Alexandre effectivement nous
sommes en mesure de donner les noms des
10 premiers sénateurs concernés par ce
renouvellement de 2023 et c'est une
prime aux sortant que l'on voit avec les
scrutins majoritaires par exemple dans
les Hautes Pyrénées les deux sénatrices
sortantes sont réélues dès le premier
tour à Tarbe il s'agit de la sénatrice
radicale Marie SCER qui est membre du
groupe RDSE même chose pour la
socialiste Vivienne Artigalas elles sont
toutes les deux réélues dès le premier
tour autre département importants les
Landes les deux sortants socialistes
sont également réélus dès le premier
tour avec plus de 60 % des voix il
s'agit d'Éric kerouche et de Monique
Lubin ils sont donc réélus aujourd'hui
en Lazer la sénatrice socialiste guyen
Pantel qui siège au groupe RDSE est
également réélu dès le premier tour dans
ce département qui renenouvelle un siège
et on le disait tout à l'heure dans la
Haute Loire le centriste Olivier
sigigolotti et réélu ainsi que le LR
Laurent Duplomb dans ce département qui
réélit de sièges on vous le disait c'est
plus compliqué dans le Lot et Garon où
il y a un scrutin qui est incertain
après le premier tour vous voyez les les
sénateurs qui sont les candidats qui
sont arrivés en tête du premier tour
avec la sortante Christine fantidossa LR
42 % des voix divers gauche Michel
Masset 39,9 ou Jean-Pierre mogal
centriste qui fait 29 % des voix autre
information formtion à prendre au
conditionnel pour l'heure car elle n'est
pas vérifiée sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur mais dans le Lot le maire PS
de cor Jean-Marc vessous serait élu dès
le premier tour et enfin on termine avec
la Nouvelle-Calédonie car c'est une
information importante que l'on a appris
dès ce matin la secrétaire d'État à la
citoyenneté Sonia baques membre de la
majorité présidentielle est battu dans
le département dans la collectivité de
Nouvelle-Calédonie et on va voir les
deux sénateurs qui sont élus il y a le
le
loyaliste qui s'appelle George naturel
qui est élu dès le prer tour et au
second tour c'est Robert xoui un
candidat indépendantiste qui est élu
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
du Sénat qu'un élu indépendantiste va
faire son arrivée à la chambre haute du
parlement Alexandre merci beaucoup
Quentin pour ces résultats dès que vous
en avez de nouveau n'hésitez pas on
viendra vous voir Émilie zapalski
toujours sur ce groupe les républicains
au Sénat ça va être un enjeu aussi de la
prochaine mandature de savoir dialoguer
avec les collègues députés LR de
l'Assemblée oui tout à fait moi il me
semble que les sénateurs LR ont tout
intérêt à continuer cette stratégie
qu'ils avaient de peser justement sur
les décisions en tout cas sur les
projets de loi qui sont proposés par la
majorité qui passent d'abord au Sénat
comme on l'a dit donc pour essayer
d'orienter un petit peu vers des choses
qui qui les concernent et vers
lesquelles il souhaitent à l'Assemblée
c'est complètement différent mis à part
retillo on a des personnalités en effet
on a des égos et on a finalement le
reflet de de candidatable enfin de
personnes qui pourrai être candidat on
voit bien Aurélien Pradier on a vu
erriic cioti qui avait été candidats
pour les primaires les républicains donc
c'est des personnalités qui ont envie de
sortir du bois à la fois sur leurs
orientations politiques les républicains
mais aussi sur leur lignes propres sur
leur personnalité donc c'est
complètement différent et à mon avis ça
va continuer à se jouer dans cette
cour-l c'est-à-dire au Sénat on est
sérieux d'ailleurs on voit bien le
contraste avec l'Assemblée on discute on
sa parler sans s'énerver à l'Assemblée
on est beaucoup plus sur des éegoos qui
veulent se montrer qui veulent marquer
leur différence y compris dans leur
propre camp on va voir comment comment
ça va se passer ça va être intéressant
ce qui m'intéresse à droite aussi c'est
horizon on en a parlé tout à l'heure
c'est on sent le le le moment post Maron
quelque part on commence à sentir la
direction le chemin vers 2027 comment ça
va s'organiser qui qui y va qui y va pas
on voit bien qu'eddouard Philippe un
Tiss un petit peu sa toile d'araignée
autour y compris au Sénat s'il a des des
postes il y a tout ça qui va se jouer il
me semble aussi dans ces élections
sénatoriales d'aujourd'hui allez on va
aller dans le département des Hautes
scèes retrouver Audrey vetaz en direct
de nanter Audrey quels sont les enjeux
de ces élections sénatoriales dans les
hautes
scènes et bien dans ce département il y
a SEP sièges à renouveler un département
très urbanisé puisqu'il n'y a que 36
communes mais 36 grosse commune alors
pour l'instant c'est LR qui détient le
plus de sièges trois et l'objectif c'est
d'en faire un de plus qu'en 2017 la
droite est emmenée par Roger carucci
Christine Lavarde et Philippe penszek
des sénateurs sortants la droite qui
part beaucoup plus uni qu'il y a 6 ans
mais il y a tout de même une dissidence
Marie doliman l'adjointe au maire
dannière a décidé de partir seule et
elle pourrait ravir cette 4e place à la
liste de Roger kucci mais les hautes
scènes c'est bien sûr le fief d'Hervé
Marseille le patron du groupe Union
centriste au Sénat qui brigue un nouveau
mandat petite surprise sur la liste de
l'allié de LR Sénat il y a une sénatrice
modem en 2e position Isabelle florenes
la fille d'un autre sénateur fille de
jean-malerie vanlerambert sénateur du
pas decalais ce qui ne fait pas vous
l'imagineer les affaires du sénateur
sortant Xavier yacovelli sénateur de la
majorité présidentielle qui aurait bien
aimé que tous les partis alliés du
président le rejoignent d'autant qu'il
le sait il ptie des liens distendus
entre Emmanuel Macron et les élus mais
dans son entourage on a confiance on se
dit qu'il est parti tôt en campagne
depuis janv janvier et que ça pourra lui
permettre de conserver son siège et puis
je termine par la gauche qui parunit
derrière le communiste pierre ououias
qui a réussi à s'allier aux écologistes
et au partis socialiste mais sans la la
France insoumise une dynamique d'union
avec laquelle il espère glagner deux
sièges ce soir à confirmer donc
Alexandre merci beaucoup Audrey pour
toutes ces explications et on va voir la
totalité des listes de candidat dans le
département des Hautes scènes pour ces
élections sénatoriales 2023 Stéphan
Vernet on voyait les différents enjeux
dans le département des Hautes scènes et
il y a et bien un candidat une
personnalité de ce scrutin c'est Hervé
Marseille qui est président du groupe
centriste ici au Sénat et Hervé
Marseille et bien il mène un groupe qui
fait à la fois partie de la majorité
sénatoriale mais aussi avec des
sénateurs qui sont favorables à Emmanuel
Macron
ouais alors ça c'est la grande subtilité
du Sénat en fait est-ce qui fait que les
choses sont parfois très compliqué à à
lire puisqueil y a il y a il y a
beaucoup de crossover ouais donc voilà
je je peux pas je peux pas pas mieux
dire euh mais comment est-ce que les
centristes vont tirer leur épingle du
jeu bah pour l'instant en fait les
centristes ils sont euh ils ont un
groupe pivot au sein du au sein du Sénat
puisque c'est eux qui qui qui qui
tiennent la boutique avec les
républicains en fait c'est comme ça que
ça voilà avec 57 57 sièges pour les
centristes 145 pour les républain donc
euh ils vont probablement ils peuvent
perdre quelques sièges ils espèrent en
gagner enfin on sera encore une fois
comme comme dans l'ensemble de ce
scrutin les ajustements se feront
probablement à la marge c'est c'est
peut-être pas du côté de de l'UDI qu'il
faudrait regarder moi je pense que ça ce
qui va être intéressant c'est regarder
du côté alors il y a il y a les il y a
il y a les sénateurs Renaissance le
groupe de de de François patria là qui
qui a
priori va être plutôt sur un sur un sur
un recul à
priori je pense que ce qui va être
intéressant de regarder c'est comment
vont se situer les les sénateurs horizon
et est-ce qu'ils vont avoir bah voilà
est-ce qu'ils vont avoir la capacité ou
pas à créer un groupe parce que derrière
il y a la présidentielle il y a la il y
a c'est ce que disait Émilie tout à
l'heure très bien c'est le on est déjà
dans le dans la dans la succession
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2027 et Édouard
Philipp il a besoin de d'ancrer son
parti d'ancrer son mouvement et de
l'affirmer et pour lui je pense qu'il
serait essentiel d'arriver à à être en
capacité d'avoir un groupe autonome
parce que derrière c'est un affichage
c'est voilà et euh pour moi c'est un
c'est le principal
enjeu je dirais au centre au centre
entre le centre et la majorité
présidentielle parce que là aussi c'est
un petit peu compliqué il y a beaucoup
de cross c'est un peu confus c'est un
peu confus on parlera des enjeux pour la
majorité présidentielle mais Bastien
François d'abord une question sur ce
groupe centriste au Sénat un groupe à
majorité udi le parti qui est d'ailleurs
présidé par Hervé Marseille c'est un
groupe dont as besoin la droite pour
bien fonctionner au Sénat
oui alors c'est c'est pas tout à fait
quand même une nouveauté hein la la la
droite je
dirais les républicains ça s'appelait
avant autrement bon a toujours été allié
avec les centristes il y a toujours eu
ce petit jeu quand même
euh des centristes hein qui sont les
centristes sont centriste en réalité non
mais je dire il faut le dire comme ça
c'est-à-dire que c'est c'est une très
très vieille histoire et lorsqu'on parle
par l'absence d'une majorité absolue
rappelons-nous mais c'était il y a
longtemps mais c'était à l'Assemblée
nationale Michel Rocard 50 % en pile des
lois votées sous Michel RC a était voté
avec les voix centristes bon donc et les
50 autes pour avec les voix communistes
he bon c'était une configuration
particulière mais les centristes sont
les centristes donc ça change de ce
point de vue là ça change pas
grand-chose effectivement on va être à
l'unité près ça va peut-être bouger à
l'unité près va y avoir tout le temps
cette les centristes en réalité là
actuellement dans la configuration
actuelle pèse sur LR dans le sens où ils
empêchent LR de prendre des positions
parfois qui pourraent être plus dur que
Cell que son président voudrait qu'il
prenne bon donc d'une certaine façon ça
va dans le sens de ça va de dans le sens
évidemment de la majorité présidentielle
bon mais il faut bien voir que et on l'a
déjà dit on est dans la perspective de
la présidentielle on a dans la
perspective des des recompositions
éventuellement à droite lié à cette
élection présidentielle il y a l'enjeu
de l'existence ou pas d'un d'un groupe
horizon et c'est ça qui va peut-être
peut-être on verra ça dépendra
évidemment du résultat c'est ça qui va
peut-être peser justement dans cette
relation entre la fraction la plus
euh déterminée ou critique de LR de la
droite sénatoriale et puis le camp
présidentiel et selon l'équilibre dans
lequel on sera selon la façon dont
chacun des acteurs va aussi anti enfin
construire sa stratégie parce qu'elle
est pas évidente du tout hein et qui qui
serait capable de J aujourd'hui quelle
est la bonne stratégie de positionnement
pour la prochaine élection
présidentielle c'est quand même quelque
chose d'extrêmement compliqué bon parce
que le paysage politique quand même a
été totalement explosé hein de depuis
maintenant 5 7 ans bon donc c'est c'est
très compliqué de se se positionner en
tout cas à droite hein à gauche aussi
mais pour des raisons plus anciennes et
peut-être plus structurelles donc le le
c'est ça ça va être ça l'enjeu les
centristes pour moi enfin je vais dire
comme ça je l'ai déjà dit les centristes
vont rester centriste maintenant avec
quel poids réel et pour quel type
d'ambition politique à à moyen long
terme Florent vadio ce groupe centriste
au Sénat c'est un groupe pivot important
dans le jeu de stratégie entre l'ELR et
la majorité présidentielle oui il est il
est pivot parce qu' il permet de
construire des majorités mais je reevens
je rejoins totalement ce qu'a dit
Bastien François et et finalement si je
devais résumer à grand trait nos
échanges c'est que chez les gros pas
grand-chose de nouveau c'est chez les
petits que se va se jouer la capacité de
bascule avec a sauvegarde ou pas du RDSE
par exemple qui est le plus vieux groupe
du Sénat le groupe radical le groupe
radical avec le groupe de Claude maluré
que va-t-il advevenir de lui est-ce
qu'il va aller vers horizon est-ce que
la majorité présidentielle va le
maintenir comme en quelque sorte une
instance
neutre un mi-chemin entre la majorité
présidentielle et le groupe horizon et
donc finalement ce qui c'est c'est un
peu ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur
les scrutins de liste c'est c'est les
tout petits qui vont avoir une capacité
d'être des des changements des acteurs
de changement et de de permettre à au au
stratégies de de s'affiner parce que
finalement plus vous êtes gros moins vos
capacités de négociation sont sont
fortes en l'espèce puisque on vous
attend sur une stratégie qui ensuite
connaît des variations selon les textes
selon le la sensibilité de l'opinion
mais franchement le la prime cette
fois-ci elle sera au petits groupes
notamment les petits groupes centristes
qui vont avoir une capacité de de de
d'envoyer des signaux très forts
politiquement
mil zapski est-ce qu'elle fonctionne si
bien que ça cette alliance entre le gros
groupe les républicains et le petit
groupe centriste car il peut y avoir des
diverggenence on le voit en ce moment
sur le texte immigration que prépare le
gouvernement les centristes qui sont par
exemple favorables à la régularisation
des travailleurs sans papi pas du tout
les républicains B oui justement ils
jouent leur carte de cheville ouvrière
qui peut enfin de rôle pivot qui peut ou
pas verser vers la la majorité donc ils
ont tout à y gagné à être un petit peu
poil à gratter justement dans ces
décisions là moi ça me fait penser au
groupe lot à l'Assemblée nationale donc
ce petit groupe qui a fait quand même
beaucoup parler de lui euh parce que euh
ils ont été à la tête d'une motion de
censure enfin il y a eu beaucoup en fait
on on se rend compte en effet que ces
groupes-là qui sont petits font un petit
peu la météo l'un pour l'Assemblée
nationale et l'autre pour le Sénat après
il ne compte pas plus que ça c'est
pareil hein c'est un moment de gloire et
de fortes exposition mais après on voit
qu'il peut pas y avoir de suite parce
que ils ne sont pas assez importants et
que leurs idées sont peut-être justement
un petit peu trop centriste pour un
paysage qui nécessite en tout cas un
clivage qui qui fonctionne bien donc
c'est intéressant de voir comment
comment ça se passe et comment il se
positionne mais c'est pas à long terme
une stratégie qui peut être gagnante
Bastien François on pourrait se dire que
finalement avec tous ces petits groupes
centristes au Sénat il pourrait y avoir
un gros bloc central de la majorité
présidentielle avec les centristes le
groupe Renaissance RDPI et puis le
groupe les indépendant avec des
sénateurs horizon mais ça c'est ce n'est
pas
possible c'est peu crédible on va dire
mais en revanche je pense qu'il pèse
beaucoup plus qu'on l'imagine parce que
ils sont quand même très adaptés à au en
même temps
macronien voilà c'est-à-dire que le H
temps macronien passe nécessairement
pour exister dans la configuration
politique actuelle où il y a pas de
majorité absolue passe nécessairement
par des petites adaptations qui
permettent de satisfaire disons plus à
droite et éventuellement plus à gauche
ou en tout cas au centre gauche donc ils
sont quand même dans une position
je dirais moins marginal que a pu être
qu'on pu être ses positions du centre
par le passé parce qu'ils sont quand
même très adapté à cette donne là et on
peut imaginer aussi que les candidats
qui vont
vouloir succéder à Emmanuel Macron dans
son camp qu'il soit plus ou moins à
droite pour le moment on on a que des
candidats de droite hein bon mais vont
quand même essayer de jouer sur cette
corde là à garder une dimension du en
même temps pour pouvoir ratisser quand
même plus large que la droite
parlementaire classique qui pour le
moment est quand même dans un mauvais
état donc je crois quand même que va y
avoir ce qui se joue là au centre alors
effectivement dans des recompositions là
il va falloir voir les choses qui se
passent dans les semaines à venir hein
bon là vraiment très tôt pour pouvoir le
dire mais risque d'avoir quand même un
un un point important dans toute une
série de choses parce que on parle du
Parlement là donc le Parlement c'est un
endroit où va faire la loi bon le
gouvernement a besoin de faire la loi
parce que le gouvernement peut gouverner
par voie règlementaire sur beaucoup
beaucoup énormément de sujets il y a un
moment donné sur un certain nombre de
sujets y compris pour des raisons
strictement politique doit faire la loi
bon et et donc là les les mois et les
années à
venir le Parlement va avoir sur lui un
projecteur beaucoup plus important que
dans dans le passé bon et ce qui va
faire la différence au Parlement c'est
justement c'est et en tout cas au Sénat
c'est justement la façon dont la droite
va se construire dans son rapport avec
le
les centres vont se construire dans le
rapport avec la droite Stéphane Vernet
si on se concentre sur les enjeux pour
la majorité présidentielle dans ces
sénatoriales et qu'on regarde et bien le
groupe RDPI le groupe Renaissance au
Sénat il joue beaucoup
aujourd'hui 24 sièges seulement 12
renouvelables j'en reviens à votre
petite introduction est-ce que
Renaissance est-ce que la majorité
présidentielle va réussir à s'imposer au
Sénat la réponse est non c'est c'est
voilà ça ça n'est matériellement pas
possible euh et un des enjeux pour pour
le groupe RDPS c'est de c'est de pouvoir
maintenir son étiage mais on on sait
déjà que qu' vont être qui vont être
confrontés à un recul la vraie question
c'est quelle sera l'ampleur de ce recul
et quelle quelle conséquence quelle
conclusion on en tire la la la défaite
de Sonia baquez en Nouvelle-Calédonie
enfin voilà c'est pour le coup c'est un
c'est un c'est un coup de tonner parce
qu'elle va symboliser ce ce ce recul
euh moi je pense que c'est la la la
traduction d'un échec euh
spectaculaire qui dure depuis 6 ans
c'est-à-dire que ça montre bien
l'incapacité totale de ce mouvement
c'est-à-dire la en marche puis la
République en marche puis Renaissance
à a créé un véritable ancrage
territorial l'échec est total c'est
quand même assez c'est c'est quand même
assez incroyable de de se rendre compte
qu'on a un président de la République
qui a été élu en 2017 sur une pyramide
inversée d'habitude vous avez un parti
qui a des bases qui construit un
candidat et donc qui finit par devenir
président de la République on a Emmanuel
Macron qui a réussi à être élu sans
parti sans mouvement et qui prétendait
construire un ancrage voilà c'est pour
ça que je parle de pyramide inversée ça
ne marche pas et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on pourra se rendre compte à nouveau que
ça ne fonctionne toujours pas on va
continuer à parler des enjeux de ces
sénatoriales pour Emmanuel Macron et sa
majorité présidentielle mais d'abord on
va retrouver Quentin Calmet qui pilote
la cellule résultat de cette émission
sur les élections sénatoriales Quentin
est-ce que vous avez des nouveaux
résultats oui tout à fait on peut vous
donner les noms des 12 premiers
sénateurs qui sont réélus dans les
départements qui élisent un ou deux
sénateurs où il se tient un scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours on va commencer
avec le Loir etcher où il y a deux
sièges à pourvoir pas d'élu dès le
premier tour Bernard pillefer fait fait
37,4 % il s'agit du candidat divers
droite Catherine Lhéritier fait le même
score ainsi que le 3è monsieur brô qui
fait
32,8 % primo sortant dans les Hautes
Pyrénées les deux sénatrices sortantes
sont réélues dès le premier tour à Tarbe
il s'agit de la sénatrice radicale Marie
scarer ainsi que la sénatrice socialiste
Viviane Artigalas elles sont toutes les
deux réélu dès le premier tour dans les
Landes également prime aux sortant pour
les socialistes Éric kerouche et Monique
Lubin également réélu tous les deux dès
le premier tour du scrutin on continue
avec la Lazer où il y a un poste à
pourvoir également prime au sortant à la
sortante puisque Guilain Pentel élu
socialiste mais membre du groupe RDSE
est réélu dès le premier tour on
continue avec la Haute Loire avec
également deux sortants réélus dès le
premier tour le centriste olivier
sigigolotti est réélu ainsi que le LR
Laurent Duplomb enfin on va aller en
Mayenne où il y a deux sièges à pourvoir
et on peut déjà vous donner l'un de ces
deux sièges il s'agit de la réélection
de ellisabeth douano la centrce qui est
également rapporteur général du budget
de la Sécurité sociale elle est élue dès
le premier tour et enfin une information
qu'on vous donnait au conditionnel mais
qui est maintenant vérifié qui est
confirmé le maire PS de caor Jean-Marc
vessous fort est réélu est élu pardon
dès le premier tour du scrutin on
termine avec la Nouvelle-Calédonie même
si c'était les premers pr résultats
qu'on a eu dès le début de la journée
puisqu'on vous le dit dans sur cette
antentainne depuis MIDH et demi mais il
y a un membre du gouvernement qui a été
battu lors de ces élections sénatoriales
il s'agit de Sonia baquz soutenue par la
majorité présidentielle en
Nouvelle-Calédonie les deux sénateurs
élus sont George naturel qui est un un
candidat maintenant sénateur divers
droite loyaliste et Robert goui second
élu de ces sénatorial en
NouvelleCalédonie c'est une première un
élu indépendantiste va faire son entrée
au Sénat voilà Alexandre je vous montre
la carte de France he puisque c'est
c'est intéressant les départements en
bleu clair qui sont des départements où
il y a un scrutin majoritaire à deux
tours qui sont en train de nous envoyer
les premiers résultat qu'on vous donne
sur l'antenne que vous voyez en bleu
clair il faudra attendre pour les
départements les plus peuplés ceux en
bleu foncé plus tard dans l'après-midi
vers 18h30 pour avoir les résultats dans
ces départements qui réalisent le plus
de sénateurs voilà Alexandre pour
l'essentiel de ce qu'on peut vous dire à
l'heure qu'il est merci beaucoup Quentin
ETM zizapalski Stéphane Vernet le disait
il y a un échec pour Emmanuel Macron de
s'implanter dans les territoires dans
les collectivités locales vous êtes
d'accord oui oui je pense que ça me
faisait rire parce que la pyramide
inversée pourtant il marchait devant la
pyramide du Louvre donc quand il quand
il a été élu mais il y a pas que ça je
pense qu'il y a en effet cet échec
d'avoir vraiment cette implantation
territoriale et de parler quelque part
plutôt du côté des métropoles du côté
urbain on a quand même cette idée làà
mais il y a aussi cette difficulté à
travailler avec les élus donc pas
forcément les élus Renaissance mais de
travailler avec les élus élus locaux je
le disais tout à l'heure ils ont été mis
de côté au début du quinquena on essaie
de les réintégrer la majorité a beaucoup
de mal le gouvernement a beaucoup de mal
à travailler avec eux et quelque part ça
se ressent là-dedans et puis il y a
autre chose c'est que le en même temps
Emmanuel Macron ben cette étiquette là
cette promesse de vente ça fait moins
vendre ça fait moins plaisir ça ça plaît
moins quelque part il y a eu un espèce
d'échec dans la pratique de la mise en
œuvre de ce en même temps qui est très
attirant dans les discours c'est quand
même Emmanuel Macron avait réussi quand
même cette candidature expresse qui
partait de nulle part en effet qui
promettait une vision pragmatique on va
faire un peu à droite un peu à gauche
c'était très vendeur et puis tout d'un
coup ben on voit que ça plaît pas
forcément et que ça fait pas forcément
vendre et que cette étiquette là ben
parfois il vaut mieux s'en passer parce
que elle est pas ça ça gagne pas pour
des pour des élections comme ça donc je
je trouve que c'est c'est un triple
échec moi il me semble pour pour
Emmanuel Macron et puis on sait très
bien que que cette étiquette en plus
quand il n'y aura plus Emmanuel Mac
Macron qui ne peut pas se représenter
ben qu'est-ce que ça devient qu'est-ce
qu'on a compris de la colonne vertébrale
de ce en même temps mis à part la
personnalité d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
aussi cet échec là avoir montré que ce
mouvement au-delà d'Emmanuel Macron
représentait quelques chose de tangible
on a du mal à comprendre c'est un peu à
droite un peu à gauche c'est un peu en
fonction de ce qui se passe dans l'air
du temps on donne quand on nous demande
on a beaucoup beaucoup de mal à voir ça
clair et quand il y aura pas Emmanuel
Macron ça risque d'être très dispersé en
vaadio finalement le clivage droite
gauche reste prignant dans ces
territoires dans ses collectivités
locales en même temps ça ne marche pas
oui et d'autant que les scrutins qui ont
permis de conduire aujourd'hui à
l'élection du Sénat c'est-à-dire les
municipales de 2020 et les
départementales de 2021 Emmanuel Macron
il était déjà sorti de laindistinction
le en même temps était déjà soldé
c'est-à-dire qu'on savait que la jambe
droite d'Emmanuel Macron était beaucoup
plus forte que la jambe gauche et et de
ce point de vue-là les élus sénatoriaux
qui vont sortir de cette soirée ils ne
peuvent plus désormais tricher tout le
monde sait très bien ce que le président
de la République a fait ou n'a pas fait
et si on reprend l'exemple du sénateur
yovelli que vous qu'on citez tout à
l'heure dans les hautes scènes il est
symptomatique c'estàdire que Xavier
ycovelli il vient de la gauche comme
d'ailleurs une grande partie du groupe
de François patria François patria
lui-même étant un ancien socialiste
comment ces élus-l peuvent aller
récupérer les électeurs qui en 2018
doutit en fait du fait qu'Emmanuel
Macron n'était pas une partie de
l'avenir de la gauche comment est-ce qui
peut aller à nouveau parler à ces grands
électeurs là en leur disant ben en fait
non la jambe gauche on va on va quand
même y arriver c'est la stratégie
électorale de ces sénateur qui est mise
à mal par les deux par le quinena qui
s'est écoulé et la moitié de quinena qui
arrive d'autant que et on l'évoquait
tout à l'heure les les ministres fort du
gouvernement actuel ont complètement
obéré l'image et donc c'est ça n'est pas
le le le le le virage de Gabriel Attal
qui est un des soutiens de de Xavier
yacovelli qui permettra d'invalider cela
donc finalement quand on avait une
sociologie électorale de gauche et qu'on
est macroniste aujourd'hui on a perdu
ses électeurs ben françoisit un mot sur
le parti horizon qui est le parti
d'edard Philippe une autre composante de
la majorité présidentielle et au Sénat
il y a ce groupe les indépendants avec
des sénateurs membres du parti Rizon
finalement Édouard Philippe il a
peut-être compris l'échec d'Emmanuel
Macron dans les territoires et il veut
construire sa pyramide pour 2027 par par
la base oui alors moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec les les analyses
qu'on vient d'entendre mais moi
peut-être je dirais pas parce que échec
ça veut dire qu'on a essayé de le faire
ce qui est tout à fait fascinant mais
même incroyable c'est que le parti
d'Emmanuel Macron n'a jamais existé n'a
jamais existé matériellement jamais bon
donc il a un moment donné quand on fait
de la politique quand même il faut avoir
un parti faut avoir des militants il
faut avoir des donc une capacité à avoir
des candidats qui ne surgissent pas de
n'importe où dans un casting qui est
fait je ne sais pas comment bon et donc
il y a quelque chose là dans la enfin
dans la dynamique même d'Emmanuel Macron
qui était bon qui a fait une sorte de
holdup sur les la sa première élection
présidentielle bon mais derrière comme
il y avait un rejet de la politique
enfin il y avait un rejet de tout des
élus et des corps intermédies et cetera
bon et bien en tout cas politiquement il
y a rien qui s'est construit donc c'est
même pas un échec ils n'y sont jamais
allés jamais bon alors ça c'est une
énorme différence avec Édouard Philippe
Édouard Philippe lui il a compris qu'il
fallait une organisation il a il a
compris qu'il fallait euh au début de
cette organisation puisqu'il partait un
peu de rien B il fallait avoir des
locomotives c'est retrouver des élus
locaux des des des des des cadres élevés
de partis politiques venus disons dans
le cas desdard Philippe de la
droite sinon il se voilà et et il
continue dans cette logique là donc
alors peut-être que ça va être enfin
pour le moment il y a pas beaucoup de
troupes hein et d'ailleurs de façon
générale il y a peu de troupes parmi
tous ces ces candidats là hein bon donc
on la vie politique va être passionnante
dans les années à venir hein parce qu'il
va se passer beaucoup de choses mais
dans le cas du macronisme euh euh il y a
pas de parti il y a pas d'organisation
il y a un mépris complet de tout ça
doublé on l'a dit de dès le début de son
premier mandat Adam m pris des élus vous
avez toutes les associations d'élus
quelle que soit la taille des
collectivités qui qui qui sont contre
donc ça fait vraiment un passif
considérable pour des élections
euh sénatorial c'est un petit peu
différent pour d'autres types d'élection
allez on va prendre un peu de recul on
va revenir sur les relations entre le
Sénat et l'exécutif depuis 1 an depuis
la réélection d'Emmanuel Macron regardez
ce sujet de Jérôme Rabier après un
premier quinena où les relations entre
Emmanuel Macron et le Sénat ont été très
compliquées avec en point d'org la
commission d'enquête sur l'affaire
benala les relations semblent plus
apaisé entre l'exécutif et la chambre
haute pas une lune de miel mais plutôt
un mariage de raison faute de majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale et donc le besoin
des députés de droite pour faire voter
les textes l'exécutif s'appuie sur le
Sénat où la droite est plus conciliante
si l'intérêt est partagé et là
évidemment vous avez besoin de dealer
avec le groupe LR au Sénat pour ensuite
dealer avec le groupe LR à l'Assemblée
nationale donc vous ne pouvez pas
réellement revenir sur le compromis que
vous avez pu trouver avec Bruno
retaillot et avec le et avec le Sénat et
donc aujourd'hui bah vous avez beaucoup
moins de derniers mots TR sur la
dernière session ordinaire si je ne
m'abuse et ces derniers mots et bien ils
sont essentiellement sur des textes
budgétaires c'est ainsi que la droite
sénatoriale a voté la plupart des textes
gouvernementaux l'an dernier mais en y
ajoutant des modifications chères au
républicains c'est le cas par exemple
pour la lopm qui donne des nouveaux
moyens aux forces de l'ordre ou sur la
relance du nucléaire avec un texte qui
abandonne l'arrê programmé de certaines
centrales et bien sûr sur le texte
retraite ou après un débat Abou à
l'Assemblée le Sénat a voté le texte
mais à ses conditions cette réforme nous
la votons parce que c'est notre réforme
c'est ici qu'elle est née nous la
voterons parce que nous l'avons modifié
c'est notre texte que nous allons voter
mais si la majorité de droite au Sénat a
su se montrer conciliante cela pourrait
se tendre sur de futurs textes notamment
l'immigration où il sera difficile
d'aboutir à un accord le problème
évidemment c'est que si vous voulez
continuer à incarner une opposition et
donc une alternative demain et de ne pas
laisser votre place d'opposition et
d'alternative au rassemblement national
ou à l'anupe ben il faut montrer que
vous clivez or aujourd'hui évidemment
sur des sujets aussi sensibles aussi
symboliques pour l'air que le texte
immigration faire des concession devient
très très compliqué et derrière ben le
gouvernement risque d'avoir des soucis
il SAG plus les échéances électorales se
profileront plus il sera compliqué pour
les ELR de s'afficher en soutien du
gouvernement et donc plus il sera
difficile de les convaincre pour
l'exécutif le texte immigration comme le
budget marqueront la fin d'année et
montreront ou non la volonté de
poursuivre cette entente cordiale amorcé
l'an dernier voilà pour ce sujet de
Jérôme Rabier Stéphane Vernet il y a une
relation qu' est encore est complexe
entre le Sénat et l'exécutif c'estàdire
que le Sénat peutê à la fois un allié
sur certains textes mais aussi un
opposant en tout cas la majorité de
droit sénatorial oui tout à fait enfin
on a vu ce qui était intéressant l'année
dernière avec le enfin pardon le en
début d'année avec le la la réforme des
retraites c'est que euh pour faire
passer le texte au niveau du Parlement
le gouvernement a adopté le texte du
Sénat des républicains et les centristes
que je vous rappelle qu'en réalité
l'idée de d'avoir euh comment un
allongement de la de de la la durée
deation de la durée de cotisation et un
allongement de la de l'âge de départ de
l'âge de départ merci c'est une c'est
une c'est une construction c'est une
coconstruction des centristes et et des
républicains les républicains
traditionnellement c'était l'âge de
départ et les centristes c'était non non
c'était la durée de cotisation et à
force de travailler ensemble au sein du
Sénat ils ont trouvé ce compromis en
disant on va on va on va actionner les
deux leviers et le en réalité la réforme
de retraite qui a été présentée portée
par le gouvernement c'est celle du Sénat
c'est celle des républicains et les
centristes au Sénat c'est ce que disait
Émilie zapski tout à l'heure sur le fait
que le le Sénat à partir du moment où le
les sénateur de droite et du centre se
disent ça va dans l'intérêt général ça
correspond à ce qu'on a poussé c'est
notre projet eux sont en capacité de
dire et ben puisque c'est ce qu'on veut
allons-y on le pousse alors qu'on a une
assemblée qui est essentiellement
politique politicienne et qui est dans
une c'est une machine à dire non c'est
qu'on est dans une opposition
systématique c'estàd que même si le
projet correspond à ce qu'on voudrait
comme il faut manifester son opposition
au gouvernement et u Macron en
particulier pour les raisons politiques
pour des raisons personnelles que
sais-je vous avez ce ce ce blocage là ce
qui va être compliqué si on parle des
grands textes à venir celui sur la enfin
la loi
immigration là vous avez une vous avez
une fin de non recevoir une demande très
claire notamment des républicains y
compris au Sénat sur les métiers en
tenstion et sur le fait qu' il faut pas
qu'il y ait de régularisation et ils en
ont fait une ligne rouge qui pose
problème c'estd que le entre guillemets
le gouvernement ne pourra pas refaire le
coût des retraites avec la loi
immigration en disant bah finalement on
va prendre le texte des sénateur et et
on va le faire autre et pour le faire
adopter à l'Assemblée parce que sa
propre majorité à l'Assemblée
n'acceptera pas qui est pas qu'on ne
conserve pas le volet que le volet
comment métier en tenstion et
régularisation ne soit pas conservé donc
là c'est pour ça que tout à l'heure je
parlais de j'évoquais je je parler d'une
formule c'est une méthode qui a marché
sur plusieurs
textes qui est intelligente qui est
intéressante mais c'est pas une formule
magique non plus là sur la loi sur
typiquement sur la loi immigration au
moment où on se parle on est dans une
impasse etis palski finalement Emmanuel
Macron il a vraiment besoin du Sénat
pour assoir ces textes législatifs bah
oui de toute façon il est bien dans une
impasse parce que comme vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure on peut faire passer
beaucoup de choses au niveau
règlementaire mais au bout d'un moment
il y a des limites donc il faut bien
avancer sur les lois euh moi je
comprends toujours pas j'avoue pourquoi
on se focalise sur l'immigration alors
oui il y a des questions d'importance
mais quand on voit ce que ce qui se
passe à l'heure actuelle dans le
contexte d'inflation et de difficulté
que traversent certaines certains ménage
particulièrement c'est quand même un peu
voilà mais bon c'est pour c'est àorté
politique aussi hein forcément et oui il
va s'appuyer sur le Sénat mais il est
bien coincé ils sont tiré une balle dans
le pied en en voulant faire les deux
volets donc c'est en même temps à la
fois sur quelque chose de STR strict sur
l'entrée sur le territoire et de l'autre
côté à ouvrir pour les personnes qui
seraient capabl de pouvoir les les
métiers en tension actuellement ça va
être compliqué moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de savoir à ce jeu est-ce que
c'est gagnant gagnant moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est plutôt perdant
perdant alors oui ça fait passer des
lois le Sénat ça a été le seul endroit
où a été voté d'ailleurs le projet de
loi sur la réforme des retraites he
c'est le puisque l'assemblé n' n'a pas
voté quelque part il y a eu le 493 au
Sénat ça a été voté donc ça a permis au
gouvernement euh voilà d'afficher cette
espèce de réussite dans ce marasme qui a
été la le le passage de la réforme des
retraites mais alors d'un côté bah les
républicains ont aidé à ça qu'est-ce que
ça leur rapporte je sais pas trop et de
l'autre côté le gouvernement a réussi ça
mais il a quand même utilisé le 493 donc
ce jeu oui il est quasiment
incontournable pour Emmanuel Macron mais
il est pas très rentable ni pour les
républicains ni pour la majorité on est
quand même dans un dans un dans un nœud
terrible au niveau parlementaire pour la
majorité B François est-ce que c'est
plutôt inédit dans la vie politique
française une dépendance aussi forte
d'un gouvernement vis-à-vis de la 2uxè
Chambre du Parlement ah oui ça c'est
totalement inédit ça sait jamais
d'ailleurs tout ce que nous vivons est
inédit hein et ce qui est très étonnant
c'est que euh tout ce que nous vivons
est inédit mais les acteurs qui vivent
cette situation vivent dans une culture
du passé on vit encore avec une enfin
voilà c'est très compliqué pour nous
penser des compromis des coalitions des
voilà des bon donc oui alors c'est tout
à fait euh c'est tout à fait euh inédit
euh je nuancerai peut-être la discussion
qu'on vient d'avoir là en disant que il
y a quand même une petite contrainte
c'est que personne actuellement n'a
intérêt à la
crise parce que s' devait a la crise ça
voudrait dire quoi ça voudrait dire une
disolution de l'Assemblée nationale hein
le Sénat n'est pas en jeu mais quand
même euh on est en train de parler d'un
système bicamiral donc bon euh euh et
donc personne n'a intérêt à la crise euh
parce que c'est pas ce qui sort Stirer
de la crise donc je pense que ça ça va
quand même peser beaucoup sur sur la
façon de de de discuter je suis pas sûr
alors effectivement là aujourd'hui a
priori il y a c'est bloqué sur
l'immigration on n'est pas sûr qu'il y
aura pas des compromis moi je suis pas
certain que l' gauche de de de de groupe
Renaissance à l'Assemblée nationale ne
lâchera pas l'affaire à un moment donné
parce que je pense que LR sera prêt à
voter et même le RN serait prêt à le
voter en en en se présentant comme un
parti de gouvernement responsable et
ceteraon voilà donc
oui le gouvernement c'est simple he il a
le soutien enfin avoir une majorité ou
réussir à faire adopter des textes au
Sénat c'est une condition nécessaire à
son activité enfin comme de gouvernant
bon c'est pas suffisant mais c'est
nécessaire donc le passage au
Sénat et d'ailleurs on le voit il
commence par le Sénat parce que sinon ça
s'arrêterait tout de suite sinon ça dire
ça serait un petit peu compliqué de
passer au Sénat après un rejet tout de
suite par l'Assemblée nationale donc
c'est la première fois que les Sénat est
dans cette
position c'est c'est évidemment
extrêmement intéressant hein parce que
le Sénat n'a pas jamais été pensé pour
ça donc évidemment là on est dans dans
l'inédit dans le fonctionnement des
institutions allez on va retrouver
Quentin Calmet Quentin puisque vous avez
de nouveaux résultats pour ces élections
sénatoriales oui Alexandre on peut
donner des résultats dans les
départements où on élit un ou deux
sénateurs les départements les moins
peuplés les plus ruraux dans ces
départements où il y a deux tours et
bien il y a certains candidats qui sont
élus dès le premier tour c'est le cas de
la centriste Nathalie Goulet dans l'Orne
qui est réélue pour la troisème fois
dans ce département et également primo
sortant dans les Hautes Pyrénées les
deux sénatrices sortantes sont réélu dès
le premier tour il s'agit de la
sénatrice RDSE he ce ce groupe majorité
de radicaux maris carer même chose pour
la socialiste Vivien artigala sera élu
également dès le premier tour dans les
Landes également prime au sortant
réélection des deux socialistes Éric
kerouche et Monique Lubin également dès
le premier tour on enchaîne avec la Laer
où un seul siège était en jeu et là
également primo sortant et Guilen Pantel
qui siège au groupe RDSE est réélu dès
le premier tour on enchaîne avec la
Haute Loire réélection de deux sortant
le centriste Olivier segolotti et le
sénateur les républicains Laurent
Duplomb ils sont tous les de réélus dès
le premier tour et en Mayenne sur les
deux sièges à pourvoir on a déjà le nom
de un des deux élus il s'agit de la
centriste ellisabeth douanau qui est
connue pour être la rapporteur générale
du budget de la Sécurité sociale et qui
est donc réélue dès le premier tour il y
a des nouveaux entrant comme dans le Lot
où le maire PS de caor Jean-Marc vessous
est élu dès le premier tour il y a
toujours une et bien une question une
interrogation sur le second siège dans
ce département et on termine avec la
Nouvelle-Calédonie puisqu'on a vu que la
secrétaire d'État à la citoyenneté Sonia
baquè était batue les deux candidats qui
ont été élus sont George naturel
candidat d'ivers droite loyaliste et
également Robert goui qui est le second
élu de ces sénatorial en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et qui est un élu
indépendantiste on termine avec non pas
un résultat mais pour l'instant les les
scores dans les Pyrénées Orientales car
dans ce département qui pouvait être
éventuellement l'un des départements
pourvoyeur d'un siège au RN on voit que
le candidat soutenu par le rassemblement
national est en mauvaise position il est
4è donc il n'apparaît pas sur cette
infographie vous voyez que et bien le
candidat les deux candidats LR sont en T
en tête le troisième candidat est
socialiste voilà Alexandre pour ce qu'on
pouvait vous dire à très précisément
14h4 sur les résultats de C sénatorial
2023 merci beaucoup Quentin Florent
vadiot je voudrais peut-être que vous
rebondissiez sur ce que disait Bastien
François à la fois le Sénat et
l'exécutif n'ont pas intérêt à la crise
ça veut dire que et bien il peut
toujours y avoir une relation
constructive pour la suite du quinquena
d'abord quand les crises viennent de du
Sénat c'est quand même des moments
extrêmement lourds dans la vie politique
de la 5e République donc il y a quand
même une une culture antirise de la part
du du Sénat si si je puis me permettre
cette expression et puis effectivement
le poids politique du Sénat il s'est
forgé dans une relation de de tension et
compromis avec Emmanuel Macron tension
sur les fonctions de contrôle notamment
où il y a une très forte intransigence
tension sur la révision
constitutionnelle où là on peut dire que
c'est le Sénat qui a mis fin au au
processus de révision constitutionnel et
puis compromis très fort on l'a vu et
l'élément le plus manifeste c'est la
réforme des retraites et je trouve que
le Sénat il a trouvver une forme
d'épanouissement sur ce point-là et
quand on interroge d'ailleurs les
sénateurs pour au sujet de de Gérard
Larcher pour sa réélection que disent-il
quasiment sur tous les bancs du Sénat le
Sénat a retrouvé des couleurs on existe
on on pèse dans le jeu et cetera et et
cette manière de peser dans le jeu c'est
sur ce ce cette stratégie de l'élastique
où on ne rond jamais et on finit soit
par s'éloigner soit par se rapprocher à
à peu près à la même vitesse et la seule
le seul élément de perturbation qui
pourrait venir en quelque sorte troubler
ce jeu c'est l'attitude du gouvernement
lui-même et on l'a vu quand même depuis
2017 il y a une forme d'inculture
politique et et cette absence de
stratégie durable ou avec des oucases de
la part du président de la République
sont quand même les les seuls éléments
de distorsion qui pourraient être des
ferments de de de crise à mes yeux donc
finalement du côté du scénna il y a pas
grandchose à regarder il faudra regarder
du côté de l'Élysée et de matigon Émilie
Z palski est-ce que finalement avec les
années Emmanuel Macron a appris à appris
je dirais peut-être à manier le Sénat
est-ce que il va améliorer sa relation
avec la chambre haute pour faire passer
ses réformes B de toute façon euh on on
le dit depuis un moment il il en a
besoin donc forcément il va s'y mettre
mais c'est vrai que je reviens un petit
peu sur eu sur vos propos euh il y a
quand même des signaux qui montrent
qu'on essaie toujours de contourner
alors Ain l'activité des élus ou en tout
cas la voix des élus et de l'autre le
Parlement je reviendrai sur toutes les
toutes les formes les organes je sais
pas de décisions qui ont été multiplié
sous les quinquenas d'Emmanuel Macron le
premier et puis là là récemment les
rencontres de Saint-Denis alors oui
pourquoi pas on se dit c'était un bon
coup de com aussi hein de dire bon bah
on va réunir les partis politiques euh
alors y compris le RN et LFI même s'il
faisait pas partie de l'arc républicain
d'après le gouvernement on essaie de
parler d'accord mais on fait aussi le
Conseil national de la refondation on
fait des conventions citoyennes et on ne
sait pas au bout du bout qui va décider
quand quand des lignes seront dessinées
qui décide au final dans ces structures
là qui sont hors Parlement donc c'est un
espèce de de c'est on court-circuite
quelque part l'activité du Parlement et
on rend un petit peu flou ces décisions
politiques qui sont prises est-ce que
c'est le gouvernement est-ce que c'est
différents partis politiques est-ce que
c'est l'assemblée pour lequel on vote
est-ce que c'est le Sénat pour lequel
les grands électeurs votent et il me
semble que ça ça rejoint un peu cette
idée de toujours aller à l'encontre de
de quelque chose qui doit se passer
normalement et et je pense que ça peut
contrarier les parlementaires moi il me
semble que c'est dangereux parce que ça
a pas de suite les rencontres de
Saint-Denis on a du mal à y voir clair
sur ce que ça va donner il y avait une
lettre émise il y a pas de réponse on
sait pas ce que ça va faire et là on
voit qu'on essaie de se débrouiller pour
faire des projets de loi avec ces
accords c'est vrai que ça donne pas des
signaux très clairs sur les lignes qui
sont dessinées je dirais même pas à long
terme mais à moyen terme alors comme on
le fait tout au long de cette émission
on va aller dans les points chauds de
ces élections sénatoriales où sont
présents nos journalistes et cette
fois-ci on va aller dans le Pas de
Calais puisque Jonathan duprièz va nous
expliquer les enjeux de ces sénatoriales
dans le Pas de Calais alors ici à haras
vous le voyez derrière moi he sur ces
images de Gaspar flamand et bien les
grands électeurs continuent d'affluer
euh dans ce gymnase ici la particularité
c'est qu'il y a un très grand nombre de
grands électeurs hein 4000 qui doivent
venir voter donc la préfecture a décidé
de de délocaliser le scrutin et de
d'installer 13 bureaux de votes dans ce
gymnase plutôt que à la préfecture alors
ici il y a un enjeu très très fort hein
SEP sénateurs doivent être élus ce soir
à la représentation proportionnelle et à
noter que le pas de Calet et bien c'est
le 3è département en nombre de sièges
renouvelables cette année au sénatorial
donc c'est vous dire l'importance ici de
ce scrutin et sur le plan politique
également et bien il y a beaucoup
d'enjeux ici hein déjà à cause de la
volatilité possible de l'électorat hein
il y a 890 communes dont 650 n'ont pas
de d'étiquette politique donc ça pourra
réserver un certain nombre de surprises
ce soir euh et il y a aussi un très
grand nombre de listes ici huit au total
donc avec une gauche très divisée hein
il n'y a pas de nup dans le Pas de
Calais euh quatre listes se font
concurrence la droite et le centre
partent aussi en ordre disp Persé avec
trois listes et cette fragmentation et
bien elle pourrait faciliter la tâche du
candidat duurn le Sénat ne compte plus
aucun sénateur rassemblement national
donc le parti d'extrême droite espère
bien être de retour au Palais du
Luxembourg et pourquoi pas commencer ici
par faire un siège ce soir en tout cas
le verdict ce sera à 18h30 ici même dans
ce dans ce gymnase à aras merci beaucoup
Jonathan dupriè pour ses explications
Bastien François peut-être un mot sur ce
double mode de scrutin aux élections
sénatoriales on le voit il y a des
scrutins proportionnels notamment dans
les départements avec des grandes villes
où il y a beaucoup de listes et c'est un
certains et puis on le voit avec les
résultats que Quentin est en train de
donner dans cette émission dans les
départements avec des scrutins
majoritaires notamment des départements
ruraux il y a une forme de prime au
sortant oui enfin ça c'est alors faut
faire un petit peu attention parce que
là c'est les résultats que nous avons
maintenant c'est-à-dire que les si
quelqu'un gagne enfin très largement on
a le rés résultat plut tôt hein donc on
a effectivement des sénateurs très bien
très bien implantés dans des
circonscriptions qui sont anciennement
de leur couleur politique hein donc il y
a d'autres situations c'est plus
compliqué où il y a par exemple encore
là on l' vu des ballottages entre les
candidats bon c'est c'est intéressant le
le pas de calé hein parce que c'est
exact ça illustre bien ce qu'on était en
train de dire tout à l'heure il y a
beaucoup de petites communes on part en
ordre dispersé pour à gauche et à droite
pour des raisons chaque fois un petit
peu différentes mais qui qui a il y a
aussi derrière quand même l'idée que
peut-être on peut plus gagner de cette
façon-là et puis il y a ce candidat RN
un petit peu en embuscade qui pourrait
faire peut-être la surprise c'est-à-dire
justement il faudra voir justement là ça
sera intéressant de voir comment votent
les les les délégués municipaux sans
étiquette hein c'estàd comment vote euh
ces ces élus locaux de ces petites
communes donc là là là par exemple le
pas decalé ça va être extrêmement
intéressant euh pour pour prendre la
mesure là actuellement de par exemple de
de la notabilisation du du rassemblement
national de son implantation
territoriale mais aussi aussi de l'état
des notables de gauche et de droite et
et là aussi donc de l'équilibre des
parties tels qui sont tel qu'on va les
lire à travers ce prisme très
particulier qui a rien à voir avec nos
élections nationales auxquelles nous
sommes habitués nous en tant que
citoyens le prisme des yeux des élus
locaux qui sont la plupart des élus
locaux sans étiquette c'est c'est là que
c'est c'est tout à fait euh c'est une
information extrê important et en même
temps pas toujours très facile à
décrypter mais Stéphane Vernet est très
fort pour justement simplifier la
complexité justement et bien l'un des
gens des enjeux c'est ce que disait
Bastien François l'un des enjeux de ces
élections sénatoriales pour les partis
politiques c'est d'essayer de parler à
des élus locaux à des grands électeurs
qui sont souvent sans étiquette oui
alors ce qui est intéressant est que je
vais rebondir et je je réponds à votre
question en faisant le lien à ce que
vient de dire Bastien François ce qui
est très vrai si vous voulez c'est ce
qu'on oublie c'est que les élections
généralistes les grandes élections auqu
on est habitué et cetera au niveau
national il y a des logiques de parti on
voit on regarde le candidat et cetera
les programmes et compagni je je pense
qu'il faut pas oublier il faut redire
qu'au niveau des sénatoriales les grands
électeurs il y a aussi il y a aussi
d'autres logiques qui sont à l'œuvre
c'est-à-dire que il s'agit aussi d'élire
un sénateur ou une sénatrice qui va
représenter les élus et donc le lien
direct entre le candidat au sénatorial
et ces grand électeurs il est
fondamental c'est-à-dire que plus que la
parfois plus que l'étiquette politique
si vous voulez la disponibilité du
candidat le fait qu'il soit implanté
depuis longtemps qu'il ait déjà eu un
mandat ou plusieurs dans le département
qui connaisse bien les gens qu'il ait pu
rendre service qu' se soit montré à
l'écoute fait que dans certains cas je
suis moi je suis persuadé que ça compte
beaucoup plus que l'étiquette ou les
idées et je reviens du coup à ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure monsieur
Monsieur François sur le fait que au
dernier législative les députés
rassemblement national qui ont été élus
c'était des gens qui n'étaient
contrairement aux années passées pas des
gens qui sortaient de nulle part c'est
des gens qui avaient déjà une
implantation qui étaient là depuis
longtemps et cetera et donc on peut on
peut on peut assister aussi à des choses
étonnantes notamment dans le Pas de
Calais mais juste juste pour ça parce
que le fait d'avoir eu 89 députés 88
aujourd'hui qui sont rentrés à à
l'Assemblée ça donne aussi l'idée que en
fait ben c'est possible il SAV faire ça
ça participe à un mouvement plus large
de de j'allais dire de légitimation de
de de ce de ce parti d'extrême droite au
sein de au sein au sein de l'appareil et
ça je pense que ça compte et je suis
trop long mais je vais juste terminer
c'est aussi c'est aussi ce que c'est
aussi ce qui fait qu'il y a un doute sur
le groupe de François patria
c'est-à-dire que le groupe
renaissanceoui parce on peut se dire
dire qu'effectivement les les les
anciens socialistes qui sont
passés comment à
Renaissance devrait payer chèrement le
fait que enfin les gens finalement se
sont rendu compte que ce nouveau ce
nouveau gouvernement était pas et ce
nouveau pouvoir était pas du tout
socialiste et pas de gauche et cetera
voilà mais rapidement l'exception c'est
que vous pouvez avoir des gens très
implantés très disponibles et cetera qui
malgré tout réussissent à se maintenir
parce que ils ont créé cette relation
dans la durée avec leurs électeurs allez
on retrouver Quentin calm puisque
Quentin vous avez de nouveaux résultats
sur ces sénatoriales oui tout à fait on
parle bien sûr un des départements et
quilise un ou deux sénateurs et
justement dans ces départements il y a
parfois un siège qui est pourvu dès le
premier tour et des questions qui se
posent toujours sur le second c'est le
cas dans la Meuse où le sortant Franck
Ménonville qui siège au groupe Les
Indépendants le groupe de Claude maluret
de la droite Macron compatible est réélu
dès le premier tour mais il y a toujours
des interrogations sur le second siège
même sit tu tion dans le Jura on
renouvelle de sièges la sénatrice
sortante Sylvie vermillet qui sort qui
qui siège dans le groupe centriste est
réélu dès le premier tour mais toujours
des interrogations sur le deuxème siège
dans ce département même chose également
dans l'Orne où la sénatrice centrice
Nathalie Goulet est réélu pour la
troisème fois sénatrice dans ce
département mais où on ignore encore le
nom du deuxème ou de la deuxème
sénatrice ou sénateur qui sera élu dans
ce département il faudra attendre le
second tour qui se jouera entre 15h30 et
17 et 17h30 cet après-midi primo sortant
dans les Hautes Pyrénées les deux
sénatrices sont rédues dès le premier
tour la radicale Marie scarer ainsi que
Viviane artigala qui elle et bien siège
au groupe socialiste toutes les deux
réélues dès le premier tour même chose
dans les Landes où les socialistes Éric
kerouche et Monique Lubin sont rélu ds
le premier tour alors c'est important et
c'est intéressant car Eric kerouche
pourrait candidater face à Patrick
canner pour la présidence du groupe
socialiste au Sénat cette réélection dès
le premier tour est forcément une bonne
nouvelle pour lui on continue avec la
loser où la sénatrice PS Guilen Pantel
est réélue dès le premier tour elle
siège au groupe RDSE au Sénat on
continue avec la Haute Loire où les le
centriste Olivier sigolotti également
réélu dès le premier tour même chose
pour le sénateur les républicains
Laurent Duplomb et en Mayenne sur les
deux sièges qui sont à pourvoir on
confirme la réélection d'éliisabeth
doano élu centriste et enfin dans le
lots également pour cette fois-ci un
nouvel entrant le maire socialiste de
cor Jean-Marc vessous fort est élu dès
le premier tour toujours des
interrogations sur le second siège et on
finit avec la Nouvelle-Calédonie cette
collectivité d'outrem qui est lit de
sénateurs avec bien la membre du
gouvernement Sonia baques secrétaire
d'État à la citoyenneté qui est batue
dans ce département c'est le divers
droite George naturel qui a été élu dès
le premier tour et on voit l'entrée d'un
élu indépendantiste Robert xouy qui va
arriver au Sénat voilà pour les
résultats que je pouvais vous donner
Alexandre merci beaucoup Quentin allez
tout de suite direction l'hôtel de ville
de Paris on va retrouver Steve Jourdain
pour parler et bien de la bataille
parisienne de ces sénatoriales Steve
comment ça se
profile ah ben je vous cache pas que
vous me prenez un peu dépourvu Alex
puisque vous le voyez derrière moi et
bien les rangs sont très dégarnis c'est
un peu un temps faible un temps mort de
cette journée électorale ici la salle
des fêtes de l'hôtel de ville de Paris
les grands électeurs se sont déplacés en
nom mais ils sont venus très tôt ce
matin peut-être pour pouvoir profiter de
cette magnifique journée ensoleillé à
Paris alors les enjeux ici ils sont très
simples est-ce que la gauche va pouvoir
faire rentrer un 8e sénateur au Palais
du Luxembourg la gauche en compte
actuellement 7 la gauche qui part uni
socialiste écologiste communiste tous
ensemble espère faire ce 8e sénateur la
droite quand à elle part désunis il y a
une liste officielle menée par la la
sénatrice Catherine Duma qui affronte en
quelque sorte deux autres listes
dissidentes de droite la droite compte
actuellement quatre sénateurs elle
espère pouvoir conserver et en quelque
sorte limiter la casse en conservant ces
quatre sénateurs et puis un mot de la
majorité présidentielle qui compte
actuellement seulement un sénateur à au
Palais du Luxembourg en la personne de
Julien Bargeton il espère évidemment
conserver son son siège mais ça semble
très très très compliqué pour lui
fermeture des des bureaux de vote 17h30
et puis on aura les résultats autour de
18h30 19h Alex merci beaucoup Steve
effectivement ce scrutin sénatorial à
Paris c'est un scrutin la
proportionnelle à un tour qui va donc
durer jusqu'à 17h30 allez on continue le
tour de nos duplexes dans les
territoires et on va retrouver Samia
dechir dans le Nord Samia vous êtes en
direct de Lille et comment se profile et
bien ce scrutin sénatorial dans le Nord
ça va être très serré
oui et ça se sentit ce matin dans les
allées des bureaux de vote on a croisé
presque toutes les têtes de liste et
personne n'était vraiment serein
personne n'ose faire de pronostic parce
qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup de listes il
y en a 16 ici pour 11 sièges de
sénateurs à pourvoir alors il en a quand
même six à gauche dont bien sûr celle du
sortant Patrick canner qui est aussi
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
on en compte quatre à droite et au
centre droit trois chez les les
indépendants et les macronistes bref
vous le voyez il y a beaucoup de monde
et tout ça ça peut favoriser le
rassemblement national le candidat du RN
Joshua espère faire un siège ce n'est
pas gagné mais c'est possible en tout
cas le nord c'est un des meilleurs
espoirs du parti de faire entrer un
sénateur merci beaucoup Samia et tout de
suite on va prendre la direction du
département des Hautes scènes avec audre
vuetas qui est en direct de Nan alors
Audrey réexpliquez-nous et bien les
enjeux dans les hautes
scènes et bien ici il y a SEP sièges à
pourvoir etr aimerait en faire quatre la
liste emmenée par Roger carucci par
beaucoup plus unis qu' il y a 6 ans mais
il y a une dissidence Marie doliman la
Mère adjointe danière a décidé de partir
seule elle pourrait lui ravir ce 4e
siège et pris l'autre enjeu et c'est
aussi de savoir que va faire la liste
menée par Xavier ycovelli le sénateur de
la majorité présidentielle qui est en
difficulté il le sait parce qu'il patit
des liens distendus entre Emmanuel
Macron et les élus il est parti en
campagne auto et ses soutiens espèrent
qu'il pourra sécuriser son siège ce
soir merci beaucoup Audrey on va finir
et bien un duplexe depuis mes où Mathias
araez est en direct pour nous parler de
ses élections sénatoriales en Mosel avec
et bien un objectif pour le
rassemblement national c'est d'avoir
d'obtenir un siège dans ce département
oui c'est l'un des objectifs pour le
rassemblement national qui compte ici
des députés des maires mais également
des conseillers régionaux sans compter
sur le fait que Jean-Louis maçon
sénateur sortant ayant rejoint Marine
Lepen en 2021 ne se représente pas ils
ont donc investi un maire rural Michel
Rambourg qui se veut le candidat des
campagnes face au métropole il y a
également quatre autres sièges à faire
cinq au total ici sur le département et
une multiplicité de listes 13 au total
principalement des listes de centre-
droit il faudra compter sur les sortants
également Jean-Marie mon mais également
Catherine bererti qui ont décidé cette
fois de faire l'union sous l'étiquette
de la majorité sénatoriale la gauche
également sera présente avec une liste
présentée par Michel vebert socialiste
soutenu par une partie des communistes
il espère récupérer le siège de l'ancien
ministre socialiste Jean-Marc todchini
une multiplicité et multiplication des
listes qui assure également une division
des voix et donc potentiellement des
enjeux et des surprises ici à suivre
moiselle ce soir merci beaucoup Mathias
il nous reste quelques minutes avant la
fin de cette émission spécial sénatorial
si on résume un petit peu les enjeux de
ces élections émila palski il y a
d'abord et bien le RN Mathias en parlait
avec cet objectif pour le parti de
Marine Le Pen et bien de revenir à la
Haute Assemblée oui je pense que au-delà
du du fait de du professionnalisme de
cette voilà des on l'a vu à l'Assemblée
avec les 88 députés un nombre important
de conseillers d'assistants
parlementaires il y a autre chose que ça
il y a aussi la thématique qui est
choisie par Marine Le Pen depuis depuis
un moment et notamment pour la
présidentielle 2022 le pouvoir d'achat
c'estes classes populair c'estes classes
moyennees qu'on a l'impression que tout
le monde se dispute on a entendu un
géralde hermanin pour sa rentrée
politique qui aè sa campagne enfin sa
campagne sa pseudo campagne puisque
c'est pas encore la campagne de 2027
mais en tout cas il accès là-dessus on
sent Édouard Philippe qui monte aussi
sur cette questionlà et finalement c'est
le RN qui avait l'initiative qui a
commencé à débouler sur ce pouvoir
d'achat sur le j'entendais sur le rural
sur toute ces territoires qui parfois
votaient plutôt communiste ou à gauche
extrême et là qui sont tentés par le
rassemblement national donc il y a
quelque part aussi ça qui est porteur
pour le rassemblement national et encore
une fois comme on le disait en début
d'émission même si peut-être ils
n'auront pas de sénateur il y a euh ce
vent-là il y a cette cette idée-là qui
est en train de prospérer que ils
peuvent être euh vraiment des bons
professionnels de la politique ils
peuvent parler à ces territoires à ces
personnesl qui sont un petit peu qui se
sentent un peu abandonné donc oui il y a
un peu péril en la demeure et en face en
miroir il y a Renaissance qui est quand
même il me semble en difficulté avec
cette annonce dont on a parlé dès le
début de la ministre euh qui est battu
assez symbolique en tout cas comme comme
comme comme perte de ce côté-là sur les
sénatoriales Florent vadiot dans ces
élections sénatoriales on va observer de
près finalement les résultats des deux
partis qui sont ces dernières années au
second tour de la présidentielle à la
fois le parti d'Emmanuel Macron et le
parti de Marine Le Pen oui le parti de
Marine Le Pen parce que milyie zapski
l'a très bien dit c'est aujourd'hui le
grand vainqueur pas des élections mais
c'est celui qui fixe une partie de
l'agenda politique qui est au cœur de
toutes les discussions dont on estime
qu'il est quasi inéluctable qu'il soit
au au deème tour donc naturellement
c'est c'est le grand acteur et je pense
même que les élections sénatoriales plus
le score sera faible pour Marine Le Pen
plus il sera facile pour elle de
poursuivre sa victimisation sur le fait
que les institutions ne lui donnent pas
la parole donc il y a pas de défaite
pour le Front national quoi qu'il
advienne et puis le parti d'Emmanuel
Macron évidemment parce qu'on l'a dit
dans cette émission la stratégie ou
l'absence de stratégie de d'Emmanuel
Macron en la matière a créé les bases de
son propre affaiblissement avec des des
des des jeunes loups qui montent dans
dans les rangs et et c'est notamment le
le quart d'dard d'Édouard Philippe même
s'il faut dire que c'est une valeur
spéculative parce qu'aujourd'hui tout le
monde vote pour quelqu'un qui est
potentiellement candidat à la
présidentielle et au 2è tour tout cela
étant très irréel donc j'ai envie de
dire si Édouard Philippe ne transforme
pas l'essai et bien ça sera la dernière
élection pour horizon importante donc
effectivement le camp présidentiel va
devoir se restructurer avec une une
incertitude majeure sur le nombre
d'acteurs la bénévolence de ces acteurs
et les stratégies qui adviendront alz on
va retrouver Quentin Calmet puisque
Quentin vous avez encore quelques
résultats de ces élections sénatoriales
à nous communiquer oui effectivement on
parle de ces départements qui élisent un
ou deux sénateurs et qui votent au
scutin majoritaire dans ces département
il y a eu un premier tour ce matin et
certains candidats sont élus dès ce
premier tour on parle au total de 34
sièges à pourvoir dans ces 18
départements ou collectivités d'outre m
on commence avec la Meuse où sur les
deux sièges à pourvoir Franck Ménonville
qui siège au groupe les indépendants
républiqu et territoire le groupe de
Claude maluret est réélu dès le premier
tour il y a toujours une interrogation
sur le deuxième siège même situation
dans le Jura on renouvelle deux sièges
et où la sortante Sylvie Vermeillet qui
est une élue centriste et réélu dès le
premier tour toujours des interrogations
sur le deuxème siège dans ce département
dans l'Orne c'est la sénatrice centriste
Nathalie Goulet qui est réélue pour la
troisème fois sénatrice même chose
interrogation sur le deuxème siège on
continue avec les Hautes Pyrénées prime
au sortantes puisque les deux sénatrices
qui étaient élu dans ce département sont
réélu dès le premier tour à Tarbe il
s'agit de la sénatrice radicale Marie
SCER qui siège au groupe RDSE et
également de Vivienne Artigalas qui est
rélu dès le premier tour et qui est
socialiste même chose pour les
socialistes mais des Landes qui sont
réélus ériqueouche Monique Lubin dès le
premier tour dans le département des
Landes Éric kerouche qui sera peut-être
candidat face à Patrick pour la
présidence du groupe socialiste du Sénat
on continue avec la Laer qui était parmi
l'un des premiers départements à nous
parvenir la sénatrice sortante Guilain
Pantel qui est socialiste mais qui siège
au groupe RDSE a été réduit dè le
premier tour enue avec la Haute Loire où
les sortants Olivier sigigolotti qui est
centriste et le républicain Laurent
Duplomb ont été réélus dès le premier
tour ce matin et enfin en Mayenne sur
deux sièges à pourvoir on a la
confirmation de l'Un c'est de sièges qui
ira à ellizabeth douanau la sortante
centriste et on finit avec le lot
puisque là c'est un entrant un nouveau
venu Jean-Marc vessous fort qui est le
maire PS de cahor est élu dans la
circonscription du Lot toujours une
interrogation sur le deuxème siège et on
finit avec la Nouvelle-Calédonie même si
c'était la première information qui nous
est parvenue ce matin la membre du
gouvernement secrétaire d'État à la
citoyenneté Sonia baquz qui est perdante
qui est battue dans ce dans cette et
bien circonsccrip
les deux sénateurs élus sont George
naturel qui est un maire divers droite
loyaliste l'autre élu est Robert xoui et
c'est une première un élu
indépendantiste qui va faire son entrée
au Sénat voilà pour les résultats
complets qu'on pouvait vous donner à
14h28 précisément Alexandre merci
beaucoup Quentin et 14h28 et bien c'est
la fin de cette émission spéciale sur
les élections sénatorial 2023 merci à
tous les quatre d'avoir participé à ce
débat et à cette analyse sur ce scrutin
et je vous donne rendez-vous à 17h30
pour une émission spéciale avec tous les
résultats des élections sénatoriales
2023 17h30 à 22h30 une émission
présentée par Thomas HUG et tamtranui
avec toujours nos journalistes qui sont
sur les point chaud de ce scrutin avec
audreé vuettas dans les hautes scènes
Samia dechir dans le Nord Mathias Arz en
Mosel et puis Steve Jourdin à Paris et
puis on décryptera dans le détail tous
les résultats de ces élections avec
Quentin calmer merci de nous avoir suivi
ce midi et puis je vous donne
rendez-vous à ce
[Musique]
soir I